this is jaco podcast number 115 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willing good
evening echo good evening war is
different for everyone who experiences
it on one end of the spectrum there are
some people who deployed to a safe area
and protected by concrete and steel and
barbed wire and their job which is
definitely a important part of the
machine but it just doesn't require them
to be put into direct combat and then
with a little luck because of that
situation they can easily complete
wartime deployment with little or no
contact with the enemy whatsoever but
they did their part and we are thankful
for that on the other end of the
spectrum there are some people that end
up in anything but a safe area they end
up in the belly of the beast they are
called on to do more than is required
and much more than could be expected and
that situation also creates a spectrum
some men find it to be too much and
instincts of self-preservation take over
and they go into survival mode and they
cower and they hide and they give up and
they wait for the inevitable but others
do what they can they try to do their
duty they put one foot in front of the
other and they reload their weapon
and they try to keep firing and that's
the middle of the spectrum and then at
the far end of the spectrum there are
those men that step up and go forward
across the threshold really across the
threshold of life and they go into the
fire and into the flame and toward the
unknown and toward death not to save
themselves but they disregard their own
safety and their own life to save their
friends their brothers and their
comrades in arms and then beyond even
that almost off the spectrum there are
those men that take that step across the
threshold of life and death over and
over and over again not because they
were ordered to not for a medal not
because of some manufactured set of
ideals but simply because that is who
they are and I'm honored to have one of
those men here with me today a son a
father an American a United States
Marine
a man by the name of mr. Dakota Meyer
Dakota
welcome to the podcast and thank you for
coming on No thank you so much for
having me I'm telling ya I'm honored I'm
honored all right as we normally do
let's start from where you started tell
us a little bit about about Columbia
Kentucky yeah you know it's uh it's a
small town you know I grew up in
Columbia Kentucky you know I grew up in
the first half of my life with my mother
and ended up going and living with my
father and you know I didn't didn't come
from money didn't come from anything
nice you know I ended up living my
father I'm adopted on my father's side
and you grew up on a farm you know it's
just just uh just um you know I'm a
simple guy it's a simple it's a simple
way of life you know what I mean and
that's this is how we grew up we you
know my dad you know he always instilled
in me and you know I have to give you
know so much credit to my father and my
grandfather's I mean I'm like you know I
mean they just they instilled so much in
me of what's right and what mattered you
know you know we're talking a lot of
your childhood was and I wrote down
these notes farmwork football and
females yeah yeah I mean that's uh that
I told you I'm simple yeah that's it
yeah you know there's not much else
it ain't Columbia Kentucky though and
you know you wrote you you wrote a book
the book is called into the fire and
that's what I'm getting some of my
information from Anna and I would say
that in the early descriptions the way
you described yourself not exactly mr.
sensitive is is what we were dealing
with back then huh no not at all
you know I was no I wasn't sensitive I
was um I was just a hard-headed kid you
know set in my ways I dunno
my dad just instilled in me my dad and
still I mean you know my dad is a man
who doesn't you know he doesn't care the
social status he's not a you know he you
know and I watch it from him he's just a
hard hard hard guy you know what I mean
and so there's not living in a house of
two men right you know me it's just my
dad yeah there's not very you know
there's not very many feelings it was
it wasn't a real nourishment to your
sense it was there was not much
nourishment yeah there's one part
they're talking about you're a football
game and you jack up your elbow real bad
and so the coach got you in the locker
room or whatever yeah yeah so I was uh
sitting in the locker room and I mean
I'd carried the ball play eighteen
nineteen times the first half and I go
in there my elbows are like just jacked
right I mean you know just getting
pounded and I remember sitting in there
and the coach like hey don't come out
next half right you know you just so you
know because it was a JV game and he's
like you know don't come out next half
and I'm gonna tell you something my dad
seemed that I didn't come off and we
were warming up for second half and I
mean he came in there and that was not
that was not acceptable the one thing my
dad taught me is you start it you finish
it check-check
now what happened to that football
career would you get you did get some
like legitimate injuries right yeah yeah
I know I got a you know I banged my knee
up real bad all my sophomore year
between my sophomore and junior year no
really recovered from it you know and so
I mean I could have went and played
somewhere like I'm not gonna stick I'm I
was here and tell you I'd had full
scholarships or anything but I could
have I could have walked on somewhere
you know probably played outside
linebacker or you know a strong safety
but you know I just I was gonna go play
football and I had planned on that I've
been through the Clearinghouse I mean
I'd done everything I needed to do to go
and you know my senior year and I just I
ended up going the Marine Corps route
now I've talked a few times down here
about the effectiveness of the Marine
Corps recruiting program which they they
have like the best recruiting numbers
but they spend the least on recruiting
of any of the military service branches
it sounds like you got rolled right into
that I did they got me they got me let
me tell you something they they got me
you know but but back but I think look I
you know the products the product with
them right like you know you know you're
either you're either gonna be a marine
or you're not gonna be a marine right
like you either have it in your you
don't like it's not you know they just
they just know how to talk to their own
right and I think that's what they're so
good at is is that they know how they
know what would have fired them up and
so they say the same thing that would
have fired them
and if you bite on it then you're the
type of person need to be a Marine if
you don't they don't want you anyway you
know I mean yeah that's a perfect way to
put it and this is 2006 2000 2006 oh and
again this isn't my I always have to
remind myself and I'll remind everyone
else while I'm at it is you know when I
joined the Navy in 1990 there was no war
going on right there was no war going on
it was just you know peacetime and
you're joining in 2006 work we reward
two different countries and 2006 things
are not going well they're a little
quiet in Afghanistan at that time but
Iraq is full bore I mean that's when I
was in Ramadi it was it was a real hard
fighting was taking place and I promised
the rest of Iraq was pretty bad so you
know for you you know you're going and
you know you're gonna go to combat I
mean that's just like kind of a given
yeah I mean I am I don't know that I
ever really understood that though until
I was in you know I mean I think that I
don't think it ever really hit me I
never really I didn't really join I
can't sit here and give you some moto
story that I joined to go you know
avenge 9/11 you want to hear something
that's jacked up yeah is I joined in
1990 and I had the opposite view for it
which is I don't know there was no war
going on Oh
seals gotta be doing things all of it
they're doing stuff you don't even hear
about that's what my attitude is and
here you were staring at war into two
different zones and you're like I don't
know for real
I know it sounds dumb but I mean like uh
you know by that time we're five years
past it yeah and people had already got
used to it right it was no longer like
oh [ __ ] right you know in like the
population you know in that just you
know the average civilian right it
wasn't and you know cuz it they've been
doing it for what five years and so you
know I didn't really think about it I
you know I honestly and you know I
joined up you know I wanted to go
infantry I wanted to fight but I didn't
really I don't think it ever really hit
me until I got into boot camp you know
and then I I really start understanding
what and when you were going boot
through boot camp at that time basically
every drill instructor must been coming
back from the battlefield all of them
yeah I mean I'm telling you everybody
especially especially in a school of
infantry oh okay stay tall everyone
had been they were Saluja yeah yeah I
mean everyone I'm being the [ __ ] yeah
you know even my recruiter my recruiter
had just got back from Fallujah dang
yeah and he'd been in the [ __ ] yeah
dang yeah so with that I'm gonna take it
to the book right now cuz you know I
think I was never in the Marine Corps
I'm pretty sad about that sometimes but
I have like read so much about the
Marine Corps over my life and hung
around with so many Marines and work
with marine so much so whenever I get to
a Marine Corps boot camp
it's like strikes a romantic side of me
at least get a little taste and and you
did it really fast which is great but
here it is and it's just like exactly
what we're going to the book again this
book is into the fire by Dakota Meyer
and here we go
so it began close haircuts to strip away
your old identity exercises to prove
you're not half as strong as you figured
simple tasks to show you that you're
mentally weak drill instructors who mock
your attempts to look tough it's right
out of the movies but it never stops
yeah and there you go you know what's
coming how many times did you watch a
full metal jacket before you win in a
time yeah I mean a time you know exactly
what's gonna happen is that even helped
no it's still no you you could I mean
you know I like during boot camp it was
the hardest thing I'd ever been through
mm-hmm but when I look at everything I
did in the Marine Corps it was easy yeah
that's the same thing with buds so first
of all when I went through buds and I
didn't know anything about buds no one
knew anything about buds is 1990 when I
joined the Navy didn't know anything
about it
and and so I always think that the guys
are coming in now you can basically
watch the entire bud you can watch the
whole thing you know what it they they
the students eventually captured the
schedules yeah and so they actually know
what's coming and you know you know how
many people it keeps from quitting none
it's still the same attrition yeah yeah
okay so it's gonna suck really bad and
now you know it you didn't know it
before yeah you even know when it's
gonna end
yeah all right back to the book the
second month is the turnaround when they
build you back up sergeant Brady made me
a squad leader meaning he yelled at me
for the mistakes and the other 10
recruits that was all right he had his
job
I had mine he busted through you get to
graduation day which was obviously
awesome and then it's I spent the next
two months at sry school of infantry
only 15% of the Marine Corps and the
army are in the infantry in today's
military there are more combat pilots
and infantry squad leaders dang yeah man
that's crazy
15% of the Marine Corps in the army our
infantry troops for the ground that's
that's a interesting figure in Vietnam
and I was talking about this with Lafe
and with actually the whole National
Front team the other day I had heard
this somewhere I heard it from hackworth
that in Vietnam the height of the
Vietnam War there was a little over
500,000 troops on the ground and it was
only 10% of those troops that were you
know infantry units that were on the
ground in combat yeah you know what I
find so interesting about that fact and
that stat when I looked at it you know
like I didn't understand it obviously
when I was in but you know what I look
at it is to understand like how much it
truly you know as the war fighter you
know I think we take for granted so many
times of what it really takes for us to
be able to do our job effectively I mean
you take it you know I mean it takes you
know 85% of the organization just to
support that 15% to put you yes
face to face with the enemy yes there's
got to be another yeah I mean you look
at ten to one fifteen to one or
something like that crazy
ten to one that's got to put you up
there yeah but that's what works and
that's well here we go breaking down and
breaking down a little bit of what the
Marine Corps is like a marine squad is
comprised of three four-man fire teams
everything you do as a rifleman revolves
around that four-man team one man
carries a weapon more powerful than
those of the others but that's a minor
point in the field you don't do anything
without those three other guys you don't
[ __ ] sleep eat or move without the other
three knowing about it yeah a marine
squad with those three fire teams is
like a boxer with three arms one arm
jabs with bursts of fire to keep the
on an off balance while the other arm
loops around a left hook with the third
arm ready to follow up wherever there's
an opening for one arm as wounded the
other two can keep fighting fire to pin
down the enemy maneuver to finish him
off
fire maneuver fire maneuver fire
maneuver and I always have to point this
out extreme ownership but you know this
is cover move this is what I was talking
about the fundamental this that's the
fundamental gun fighting tactic yes
fire maneuver I was called a cover move
so you get done with SOI
and you head out to the third Marine
Regiment in Hawaii yeah that's how was
that when you checking in oh yeah well
we pulled in and as soon as we pulled
the busts in the seniors you know
they're all day at all just got back
from hadeeth of the triad and I had a
hard deployment a heart they got the
[ __ ] kicked out of them and and so we
pull in an eight you know there's no
empathy there and so we pull in and
they're throwing beer bottles off the
deck and they are all hammered it's in
the middle of the night and you know
it's like welcome you know but it was
awesome you know I was honored to be out
there and then how long did it take for
the sniper billet to open up and for you
to get that yeah so it was a things like
around February so I got there in
October so September ok no so I got
there in October November so November
timeframe I think I got to why October
and November timeframe and then I it
opened in January February timeframe is
it hardly goodest night isn't it hard to
get a sniper bill did you get lucky
a new guy get a sniper bill yeah so I
did so I was actually the youngest
sniper in the Marine Corps in 2007 so
what happened was is I had ran the in
dock so you have to run an in dock to be
part of the platoon so you come in and
then like you you're on probation so you
run a huge in dock you come in you go on
probation and then you start you know
usually you were going deployment and
then after deployment you go to school
well they had a couple school slots open
up and score and they basically gave me
the option of you can either go home on
pre deployment leave because we were
heading Iraq you need to go on pre
deployment leave or you can go to
snipers how old were you I was 18 how
many milliseconds did it take you to
make that decision
I said I've been with my family for 18
years I'm I'm all good
that's awesome and then Marine Corps
Sniper school that's it that's a
hardcore school yeah and 50% of trician
rate yeah seals in it with it yeah and
then you know our early SEAL snipers you
know and I don't know the four I'll
bring a sniper on here someday that
knows the whole history of the SEAL
sniper program but it's deeply rooted in
a Marine Corps sniper program deeply
rooted just like all of our training is
rooted in the Marine Corps Scouts and
Raiders there's a lot of crossover and
those early days but the Marine Corps
sniper program now everyone's gonna
think that's the civilians gonna think
like oh you're sitting on a gun shooting
but but that's not really the hardest
part is it that's like 5% of the job
like it's like it's I would say yeah I
would say it's less than that you know
it's you know I mean you gotta I mean
the communication piece of at the
mission planning the I mean there's so
much I mean you literally you literally
are the you know the commanders the
battalion commanders trigger finger
mm-hmm you guys do a heavy stocking
right yeah that's just a gut check with
how much did you weigh at this point Oh
probably about 180 185 and it's where do
you guys do your stocks since we're in
Hawaii so I went to Hawaii Sniper school
okay um and we do them out in the Kahuku
Alton just dripping sweat Oh laying in
there like crawling talking is terrible
it's crawling for four hours and going
35 meters yeah I mean just like you know
you know you start off you got a
thousand-meter Lane you know and there
they put an observer up and they're
using the best glass there is and
they're sitting on this truck and you
have to you have to move up and you got
to get within you know a certain
distance and whatever they tell you and
then you got you know you'll have to veg
up and whatever you take shot you can do
whatever you you know just you take a
shot with a blank okay and then they
come over and so they better walk around
you a walker on you and then they try to
walk you know back and forth they try to
find you if they see you or anything
then you know you lose and then you
gotta take a second shot while they're
you know because that Walker gets within
the vicinity of you
like it's like 10 or 20 meters and then
you take a second shot and if they see
anything then you you know you you fail
too so it's you know yeah what's a
walker so basically they bring a guy out
who is like who you know has like a
stick or something and they can see him
and then they tried to say so they go
okay I think I see him here so I need
you to take left three steps and then
back four steps they try to walk him on
you gotcha
this will be interesting wait when they
get to you do they say
sniper your feet to the guy huh so yeah
yeah they say it sniper at your feet so
that's that's the same thing that they
say in the seal Sniper school they say
to get there and they go okay sniper
your feet yup you're busted you fail
three three steps left two steps up
sniper at your feet yo no se nope so
there's there's the crossover that shows
you that that's that stuff is Rudy
together and there's a guy by the name
of skin two who was one of your
instructors you one of your instructors
right yeah and here's a here's a going
back to the books Kinta told us about a
sniper team in an overwatch and a half
constructed building in Ramadi in 2004
it was a warm dull day and after several
hours they dozed off and never awakened
insurgents sneaked up and shot all four
Marines in the head they left behind a
high-powered m48 a three and it's
excellent Schmidt & Bender scope over
the course of the next year they
allegedly killed two more Americans
before a Marine sniper took them out and
recovered the rifle skint hammered home
his message know every aspect of your
job and never never let down your guard
know if you slack off or you take things
for granted you die he I had a look I
was fortunate to have a lot of people
around me that influenced me I mean I'm
I'm nothing special I'm the product in
my environment and my um and I'm direct
reflection my leadership I'm so
fortunate but I'll tell you right now
that uh what I did that day was because
him was it was because of the mentality
that he instilled in me of knowing your
job knowing it and obsessing with it and
knowing every aspect of it and knowing
everybody else's job around you and then
when you know your job and you know
what's right you you do that you don't
worry about what everybody else says
yeah the the the noncommissioned officer
that again they're saying guys that
raised me in the SEAL Teams have such a
huge impact and what what I also found
interesting about this was this story
about these snipers when I got to Ramadi
in 2006 we heard this exact story and
you know it was another thing that made
us more paranoid and made my guys more
paranoid being out there and we actually
thought I didn't
this says 2004 we thought it happened a
little bit later and closer to our
deployment but yeah man
just just a nightmare yeah another
little commentary from you here back to
the book shooting another human being
was a math problem you were either right
or wrong with no subjective in between
decided by someone else
I liked problems that were black and
white life or death before taking a shot
at a target 1000 meters away you had to
calculate the effects of the light air
at altitude wind humidity angle of fire
cartridge velocity and gravity you had
to align the target the background and
train the weather the noise and the
weapon you had to work in concert with
others at the same time the target enemy
was figuring out how to kill you combat
was a zero-sum decision-making played
for the highest stakes live or die and
if 31 people started the course and 13
people graduated yeah so that that
should tell everyone why that sniper
designation is so damn hard to get
because it's no joke and there's usually
at any point time there's not there's
usually around 300 school trained
snipers in the Marine Corps at any time
really Dane yeah that's a my task unit
which is about 40 SEALs we had 13
snipers yeah got lucky you know I got
lucky these stars aligned okay so now
you're trained up and then in 2007 you
deploy you deployed to Iraq I did first
deployment how pumped were you I was
pumped I'm you know I just I just got
out of school trained sniper man you
know I'm ready to go I'm ready to go
turn the heat up right and and where we
were going was actually a bad spot I
mean we were in karma you know and it
had it had been bad but it was like we
were part of
Serge mm-hmm and when we got there we
took some contact once and just like the
waterfalls turned off you know you go
from streets that you're fighting down
to next thing you know you mean you
could walk down an old gear and so what
were you guys doing just doing patrols
we were doing a lot of dwell ups which
is what we go out basically what they
were the theory on this was we would go
out off the fob and stay like four or
five days into the house and you know
you know we would get hit by indirect
fire you know some but I mean but I was
only there for like 45 days and then you
got I got hit in the hand we go what I
drew got bit on the right hand my right
hand by a spider and actually suffered
severe nerve damage lost the movement my
last three fingers and I think as evac'd
you for this yeah
or medevac you back to Germany yeah so
they sent me Dallas on and tried to fix
it there I did they rushed me and I had
two surgeries in camp Fallujah and then
they they move me to al-assad and they
sent me back to Germany and I was there
for like 25 days and the hospital trying
to save your hand basically and then
they sent me home and then I was having
to occupational therapy to get you know
to get my fingers back they wouldn't
move you know when were you back in
Kentucky
no I was back at Hawaii ok back to
Hawaii oh yeah all right my unit and but
you did have a little bit of Kentucky
with you there in the form of bourbon
yeah yeah a lot of it I was drinking it
how's the drink started getting after it
a little bit I did and even a little bit
too much yeah too much you know I
started you know it's hard it was hard
coming home and knowing my teammates
were still over there and knowing that
my unit was still there and I wasn't
part of it you know and then did you go
did you have to go back or you came back
to states like on leave no no after you
were after your hand was hurt yeah yeah
yeah so I came back to Kentucky gotta
and you hung out there for a while it
actually you lost a couple friends at
that time didn't you I did get with
tragical tragic situation yeah it was
terrible you know I had a guy the guy
you know actually you know his name's on
my chest and he we played football
together and yeah he had called me I was
leaving the hospital
and I was coming home that weekend and
he had called me he had called me right
before I was on the way the hospital I
said hey
and we're gonna go to this football game
you know we're gonna watch my little
brother play you know all that and I got
a call as soon as I was leaving the
hospital and he had he'd had a trach and
got killed
yeah a close friend and I lost another
friend she got she got killed in
December dang not exactly what you want
to go home on leave for man that's harsh
no no no but you know it's it's just the
way the way it goes you know yeah and
and then so you spend that time with
home you go back to rejoin your
Battaglia and this is when you find out
that they want volunteers to go help out
in Afghanistan yeah so we built up we I
was back probably a year year and a half
went to Mountain Sniper school and you
know I became in charge my own team got
we got married totally promoted I was
you know I was the Lance Corporal
leading a five man team with a sergeant
on it you know and you know I ended up
taking like I had the worst like I got
like the newest guys they gave me the
newest guys and we ended up being the
general support team so we moved all the
way up to the platoon and
ended up being you know one of the best
or the best team ISM Stern and yeah so
we're out at 29 palms doing our final
training up to go back to Iraq and this
was when nothing was going on 2009 I
mean they weren't letting you leave the
wire right and we had no mission so it
kind of sucked right and they came and
said we need five volunteers go to
Afghanistan and I said what's the
mission they said we don't know but we
just need five bodies I raised my hand
said yeah I'm ready to go again like how
many milliseconds and so what you were
volunteering for you find out later is a
embedded training team advisory to
explain what that's all about
so an embedded training team is where
they take you know they take different
ranks and different skill sets of
Marines and they put them or you know
whatever you know military unit and they
put them together and they embed them
with you know an Afghan unit you know so
we were embedded with 80 Afghans a whole
not a it was a company mm-hmm and so
that's that's we just lived we did
everything with them we did everything
from you know teach them weapons tactics
and and you know shooting shooting we I
did the changeover for the NATO weapons
right so we took them from Kenobi to the
NATO weapons and that's another key
that we need to bring up to talk about
in that gunfight so we were teaching him
on that qual and I'm all and that you
know everything from everything and we
did everything with these guys because
and then did you any kind of workup
before you went over yeah so with that
was it with that team yeah your actual
team that you're gonna deploy with yeah
so we did we did a workup with them you
know I just left 20m palms I go back and
we trained for like a month or two in
Okinawa Japan with this new team and
then we head back to tween up mom's and
then we go from what we went back so he
went to Bridgeport and then we came down
28 palms we did all our mountain stuff
at Ridge for all our mules and all that
stuff you know packing and then we came
down and did it ended in 29 palms and
then we headed over and that was with
that four-man team yeah with lieutenant
Johnson Gunny kenefick in doc late
myself I'm gonna talk about those guys a
little bit here in the book lieutenant
Mike Johnson's four-man team at Monte
this is where you end up place called
Monte which is ten miles worth north of
another fob called Joyce
lieutenant Johnson sunny and smiling
with an easy laugh but completely
professional with the highest standards
I had climbed mountains with him in
California of course and I knew he was
as strong physically as he was mentally
staff sergeant Aaron kenefick was a
personnel specialist with eight years
expertise in administration so his job
was to bring some order to the Afghan
personnel procedures and prep a Records
da Clayton our corpsman would provide
some basic medical care to the Afghans
and the villages but his primary job was
to be ready in case any advisors or
Afghan soldiers were wounded I had a job
to lieutenant Johnson put me in charge
of tactics operations and weapons
training before each patrol I approved
of the Afghans scheme of maneuver
inspected the radios and guns
coordinated fire support and planned an
emergency escape route this was far
easier than planning the sniper missions
I had been trained for so you you were
you were kind of the most tactically
savvy guy in the group being a sniper
already deployed to Iraq ya know I was
and you know and what will prepare me
was my
training that I deal with my team you
know my sniper team I mean look I had
you know if people thought I was crazy
they thought I was crazy the way that I
was training in my platoon before you
like we're going Iraq we're not gonna do
anything I'm like I don't give a [ __ ]
right like I was still learning tax at
and I was still learning
you know SATCOM and I was still learning
HF and I was still learning how to lower
crypt I mean I wanted to know every
aspect of every part of the job I was
learning every I was going over to the
to the BAS and learning you know all the
medical stuff that I could and I was you
know I mean everything I could do like
if I could get just a little nugget of
knowledge and better myself in every
aspect I was doing it and so yeah so
when I got over to this team I mean you
know I I was the only tactical guy in
there you know and yeah and it was you
know they were they were when it came to
the tactics when it came to making sure
that the weapons were ready when it came
to making sure that the vehicle is
already that the that the you know that
the jammers were working that you know
what if anything that mattered in the
patrol it was always on you yeah the
trucks were loaded and the reason that
the Marine Corps put the teams together
like this is because well that they're
trying to develop the whole Afghan army
every aspect of it not just the tactical
side but they want like the
administration so that people can start
getting paid on time and the
organization so they got the lieutenant
in there and at the same time they
wanted to help the villagers so they put
a corpsman in there so do medical work
so that's kind of just a name if
anyone's thinking why the hell would you
put together a team like that it's
because the people that are supposed to
do the fighting are actually supposed to
be the Afghans right and in the team is
there to support them help them train
them and get them ready
yeah and that's that's the mind that's
the theory right the theory is you train
you train them and they do the fighting
and you're just there to advise them
right but it never works that way
it doesn't work that way in Iraq and and
one of the things that I pointed out
many times was you know what kind of you
you want to develop a relationship with
with a group right and and now you say
okay we're gonna train you but when it
comes time to do something dangerous you
guys just go by yourselves
that's not you're not build a
relationship you're you're in fact
you're going backwards no it's yeah it's
the same way so you get there and you
start doing your
kind of going on patrols going on
patrols with the with the Afghan yeah
army company it was kind of interesting
you know cuz I was kind of the
high-strung went on the team you know
like I was like the one that always was
you know we need to be ready to fight
you know I don't know how many arguments
I got into with some of the the the
leadership in teams you know cuz we we
were 21 man team but we were broke into
four main elements and spread out you
know and in this area and I don't know
how many times I got into arguments with
people in the team of you know hey this
is how we need to do it we need to stay
up I mean I was I was trying to train
him I was doing stuff of you know trying
to train him to do IVs at night with
like nods and they're like why the hell
are we doing this you know I mean like
and a lot of people you know look down
on it and and I said I'm going to
prepare to fight and they said you know
we're not you know they so many times
leadership got on me we're not going
over there to fight we're going to
advise and that was the mindset of a lot
of this now I'm not gonna say my team
but a lot of the team and and it showed
yeah yeah you know for everyone out
there that's wearing a uniform right now
man be ready for the worst-case scenario
all the time you know ready for it you
know what I tell him is I said you know
lieutenant Johnson was a was a calm guy
satellite guy doc Layton was a blue side
Corman and Gunny kenefick was an s-1 guy
you know and I always wonder do you
think that they ever thought they'd be
in one of the deadliest battles in
Afghanistan do you think they ever
thought they didn't you know you don't
know where you're gonna be at but one
day you're gonna be tested yeah you
better be ready so you guys are rolling
out on these patrols here's a good kind
of aspect of what you see on those
patrols and you call the army the Afghan
army soldiers ass cars if I say they're
called a scar a scars all right here we
go back to the book when we walked into
some Hamlet's you could feel something
was wrong when kids threw rocks at you
you knew what the parents were telling
them sometimes the ass cars grabbed the
kids soccer balls and sliced them apart
this didn't win any hearts and minds but
it did stop the rocks
whenever the elders hurried through the
ceremonial tea though I'd watch the Ass
cars when any soldier senses danger he
crouches down a few inch
to make himself less of a target when
the a scars did that I went on full
alert ha Fez am I saying that right so
his name's Fozzie also I had named him
ha Fez and that to protect him got it
he's how he's here in America now ok
well good ha Fez was our lead
interpreter and we quickly learned our
best warning system at a 37 year old
sergeant major retired from the Afghan
army ha Fez had served in Kunar for
three years with advisor teams the
Afghan soldiers distrusted him because
he refused to support their never-ending
schemes to skim off the Americans so
he's your your most trusted advisor
interesting that you point out how when
when soldiers sense danger and I was
telling about JP my with the lead sniper
and one of my two platoons and tu
bruiser and when he came on the podcast
I described him walking through the
streets and you and I was like I told
you man I don't think JP was gonna live
cuz JP was too brave for his own damn
good yeah but when I you know I'd be
watching I'd be like like holding
security and watching a patrol go and
you'd see you know I see guys moving
with that little Crouch because
everyone's expecting that the shootings
gonna start and I'd see JP man walking
with his head up in his chest out like
ready to get so that's my brother Jay
and the other thing that you know when
you're in these foreign countries when
we were in Iraq you're in Afghanistan
the the locals we can't tell the
difference between we really can't tell
difference we know goodbye bad guy now
you learn some sense of it when you go
okay that guy look shady and you're
probably pretty accurate about the a guy
like of half as you gonna know no you
don't know instantly he was the
unofficial fifth member of our team
inside a hamlet if he shook his head at
us we knew his time to forget the tea
and get out so how much good how much
how often would you go into a hamlet and
people cool and all good and drinking
tea and you know most time I mean most I
look I mean look uh you know the people
there want that I want it to be better I
mean they live in the shift yeah
they live there they want to be better
you know they're just caught in a bad
situation it's not a it's not a it's not
a simple equation you know there's
nothing
simple mm-hmm about the life that they
have to live you made some friends going
back to the book in the hills along the
Pakistani border no Afghan military or
civilian had much of anything
I think practically every American
soldier marine tried to help in some way
we purchase candy and trinkets in the
markets to give the kids I soon had two
little buddies boys about 10 or 11
they'd hang around the main gate yelling
my aid I'm a dad trying to say if when
they saw me at first I'd buy him cokes
and then started sharing my care
packages from home soap candy peanuts
gun gum maybe a decade from now some
kids remember that some Americans were
kind to them even when their older
brothers were shooting at them maybe not
you don't help out because you expect
something in return so you're you're a
human being man trying to try to take
care of some kids a lot of there I think
this is getting into your first sort of
legit we'll call it combat yeah and
you're taking some small arms fire I'm
going to the book here
Staff Sergeant kenefick was standing
outside a bunker about a hundred feet
from me Meyer were under attack yield
technically yes but the shepherd there's
some Shepherd out there but the shepherd
was shooting without poking his head up
to aim he had one chance in a thousand
of hitting us a second harmless harmless
burst followed the bullets cracking more
than ten feet above our head call for RT
now Staff Sergeant Ken effect yelled
holding the radio I had headset out
towards me oh nice Staff Sergeant soon
to be gunnery sergeant kenefick needed
the lowly corporals help I trotted
toward him stopped assumed parade rest
postures armed locked behind my back
chest pushed forward in the wide open
and pasted a respectful expression on my
face what does the Staff Sergeant wish
the Corporal to do another burst from
the aka this is no time to be a smartass
Meyer a few more rounds still way too
high
unlocked at parade rest high Staff
Sergeant he balanced the headset
considering whether to throw it at me
Meyer hurry up he had started calling in
the artillery mission and when I got to
him he was asking me what do I say now
left one
dropped 200 I said he repeated it on the
radio what now he asked fire for effect
I said should be dead on okay fire for
effect he repeated over the radio and
that's it you hit the guy but it to
funny that you even in that situation
you were talking about being a kind of
wiseass when you're a kid you're still
alive s yeah you know the thing about
kenefick was medium were butting heads
real hard at that time you know we were
butting heads you know how some people
just take over like he took over and
tried to make up for his lack of you
know nothing against him he was in a
combat I mean it wasn't his job but what
he tried to make up for in the lack of
his combat knowledge was his authority
right and so you know he had kind of
pissed me off pretty bad about you know
asking me to do you know can you stand
prayed rest like he was all big on it
right and it's like we're on we're on a
cop like you know we you know you still
need to know customs and courtesies
right and so I got use that that
situation to make a point you know he
just kind of pushed me over the edge but
after that we were that's what kind of
bro do you guys not right yeah broke ass
you know that's all okay you had some
good Afghan soldiers and under you were
talking to me about them and early one
guy that by the name of Dodd Ali here
you go he was fun to talk to open
friendly and fearless we'd sit around
talking and asking questions of each
other like kids in middle school
learning as much as we could about each
other he proudly cleaned his saw five
times a day and absorbed every tip I
gave him about shooting he was the most
disciplined a scar on base that's why we
gave him the saw in the first place she
had good relationship with that yeah I
mean I had a good relationship with all
my Afghans I mean I I at least two meals
a day with them you know usually I
didn't eat breakfast with them I would
eat it over at the over at the you know
the chow hall but I used you know that
was my that was my policy I mean every
night I eat dinner with them every
single night I would eat dinner with my
Afghan soldiers mm-hmm because I was no
better than them yeah you know sometimes
I hear I hear people you know people
that don't understand at all what was
going on in Iraq or Afghanistan they'll
you know we were occupy was occupiers
and how could you and it's like I always
remind them like
we were fighting alongside the Iraqi
soldiers fighting alongside the Afghan
soldiers yeah I mean spilling blood yeah
I mean we weren't I mean just cuz it was
Iraq and Afghanistan war we weren't
fighting Iraq and Afghanistan we were
fighting with them mmm we weren't
fighting against Iraq or Afghanistan xed
to them you know we were helping them
against the same enemy yeah you know so
many people missed that point manna
dey's up it's an important point to be
missing it's a big factor man I hear
that and it just turns my stomach man
now I kind of joked about that that
first situation being your first combat
and now you had legit your first kind of
trial by fire yeah you're at combat
you're at the outpost at cop Monti and
you're under attack you actually got
some wounded some a scars are wounded
and you're here we're going back to the
where stat we're Staff Sergeant kenefick
I yelled doc Layton pointed toward the
northeast Tower get over there and stay
with him I yelled suicide bombers
sometimes rushed the wire trying to take
and take an infidel with them as they
evaporated in a red flash without
hesitating doc Layton ran down the
stairs across the open space and into
the tower with Staff Sergeant kenefick 2
or 3 seconds later a rocket slammed into
their bunker exploding into pieces and a
half grand worker huddled there behind
beside the sandbags smoke rolled out of
the tower they're gone
I yelled the Johnson not believing what
I just seen I resumed firing it's all
you can do the best first aid at that
point was to return fire Johnson worked
the radio Fox 31 Fox 3 1 this is Fox 3
staff sergeant kennefick doc Layton come
on answer up we kept firing but it
seemed unworldly now we were on
automatic lieutenant Johnson got on the
radio again 3 1
Fox 3 1 this is Fox 3 staff starting
kennefick dot Layton come on man answer
up then finally yeah yeah this is three
one we're good
ten minutes later our attack helicopters
began strafing runs low rumbling birds
like a giant Burpee incredible firepower
those lovely birds enemy fire ceased
attack over Johnson and I ran over to
the bunker a staff sergeant kenefick and
Doc late and stumbled out
four of us sat on the bloody sandbags in
the growing dust talking about it their
eyes were slightly glazed and wide wide
open
lieutenant John Johnson Staff Sergeant
Ken effect and doc Layton weren't
infantry they had considered that by
coming to Afghanistan they might die but
it hadn't kicked in until now now they
had heard the screams and seen the blood
everybody soot-covered understood now
that if we went home together it might
not be alive the ass cars were cleaning
up the bloody mess not six feet from us
taking away the rip the body of their
friend we mumbled some stuff all of us
were too embarrassed to talk about our
feelings but we knew what we were all
thinking this [ __ ] was for real and
there were only four of us we'll be
there for each other doc Layton said the
surfer dude surprised me he had said the
one thing that made any sense yeah that
was um that was the Sunday before so
gang call was on a on a Tuesday that was
September 6 of 2009 it was a huge rocket
attack I mean they were dialed and it
was terrible like I can remember it as
if I was there it was terrible coming
rocks their fire I think we had nine
that hit that 107 that hit dead-on like
in not just nine that hit just inside of
of not the whole base but just my Afghan
based it's it's probably just you know
where we're at right now is probably
bigger than that it was terrible mm-hmm
and that was a wake-up call oh it was
for all of us I mean it was for all of
us and it was for the Helmand you know
I'll never forget you know I'll never
forget talking I mean we finally sit
down and talked about what do we do if
we lose one of it you know what do we
want and gosh it was so real and you
know I'll never forget kenefick I had a
I had medevacked out a guy a wounded
soldier that day and he was put me in
for a Bronze Star and I never forget he
we were walking through
in the end little hooch and he said and
where we lived that and he was just you
know kind of joking a little bit later
on that day he's like he'll Meyer you
know the way shits going for you and
it's unlucky as you are he goes you'll
probably be in for a Medal of Honor
before this deployments over with and
it's just crazy yeah that's two days
before you guys head down to ganja Gaul
we'd actually got the call that night
that we were supposed to go to Gangi
Gaul in the seventh and they ended up
pushing it right to the 8th so we left
the next day we talked about a little
bit here ganja Gaul laid two miles north
of Joyce and we drove right by the mouth
of the valley Gangi Gaul sounded like
the name of an Irish town full of
smiling faces and friendly pubs I could
see a few of the larger compounds far
back on a hillside nestled against steep
ridge lines bad place half has muttered
bad people so you're getting right away
getting told I mean we were told
instantly I mean we were told like I
mean we I mean yeah there is no doubt
now one thing that I think made you feel
more calm a little bit more comfortable
you talked about in the book
historically the Taliban had not sprung
ambushes from inside villages so that
wasn't discussed at the briefing plus we
were going in with 90 Afghans and 15
advisors with a platoon from 1/3 to
deployed behind us in a Quick Reaction
Force this shows us this show belongs to
the to our Afghan counterparts
Fabio mess in that right yeah Fabio
Fabio said we advisers will stand off to
the side and let them talk with the
elders were not in the lead we're
assisting that made no sense I thought
considering who is doing the briefing
and who was hearing it we were into the
tactical lead even if we claimed
otherwise that's a little that's a
political thing yeah I mean I I think
it's an ignorance thing well I think
it's an ignorant thing too but the
reason it happened I don't know of
course I mean technically we fail under
so I mean technically the way that this
works as crazy as this sound
I was working for like my commander was
Afghan commander whatever the Afghan
commander told me was what I was
supposed to do right I mean I'm saying
that's a political thing for us to say
politically look the Afghans are running
this operation yes yes yes I mean that
you know but that if you remember what I
said a little bit earlier about you know
hey we're not going to do the fighting I
mean you know that that's the mentality
of the leadership of team yeah yeah not
good then as you've just said here that
made no sense I thought and you were a
corporal 20 how old were you I was 21 21
years old and you're looking at this
going hey man this doesn't make any
sense we're the ones that are sitting
here briefing it you know we're the ones
that know how to call for fire yeah I
mean and I brought it well I mean first
off first off the Afghans can't even
talk to anybody that calls for fire or
the helicopters I mean they don't even
have any comms with them their own HF
yeah yeah yeah I mean I so the three
main factors that I brought up in the
brief and I brought up that look we're
only everybody's going in we have over
12 different moving elements between the
Opie's and different teams inside this
Patrol all on one frequency mm-hmm I
brought that up I brought up the fact
that we didn't have direct air
supporters on 15 minutes triple er and
that's in Jalalabad so all and you know
so they were taken as if the birds would
be there within 15 minutes I said that's
not what 15 minutes triple our meetings
they're up that means off the ground 15
minutes and then they still got nine or
probably 60 minutes to get from
Jalalabad to us and so you know that was
other factor than the other thing that I
brought up was why would we put our
snipers 2,000 meters away from the
village outside of their effective range
of their weapons there you go but here's
what I was told I'm an e4 in the United
States Marine Corps what do I know about
mission planning and that's why I was
taken out of the team Chuck
so when you say when you talk about
getting taken out of the team explain
how that went down a little bit so you
got your four man team team Monty yeah
same money and so what they did was is
you know they had theirs like they would
put the team's you know you would go
with your Afghans in here to do their
part so our team was supposed to go to
the back of the village cover the
backside of it and then we were gonna
search a couple houses up there for a
machine gun and while the meeting went
on and they took me out of the team
because I brought up those concerns and
you know they kind of took it as me
going against orders questioning their
authority and they replaced me with
Gunny Gunny Johnson so I'm just gonna
just have to say this right now so I
talk about this all the time and if
you're in a leadership position
you don't want yes men you don't want
yes man you want
the Corporal that says hey boss I don't
understand why you do that right now and
if your answer to your subordinate is
because I said so or it's purely for be
quiet or you're an e5 be quiet if that's
what your answer is that means you don't
have a real answer that means that what
you're doing is probably wrong
so surround yourself the best people you
can have on your team or the people
they're gonna question what what it is
that your your plan is and if they
question it you can't don't have a good
logical answer and your plan doesn't
stand on its own two feet well think
about it
and reassess it and take some advice
from down the chain of command on how
what we could do to change this plan up
I mean it was look they're complacent
you know that's that's the type of
mentality you have when you don't expect
to go get your ass handed to you mmm
that's why you need to expect to get
your ass handed to you every day and
train like it yeah you know I I used to
when I was running attorney we trained
for worst-case scenario all the time I
was like washing me you know what any it
it was it was insane like we had great
we had great financing for our training
so the training was awesome we had
mayhem going on we had paintballs and we
had laser this multi-million dollar
laser tag system we had roll players and
it was awesome and I wanted mayhem and
we would put guys down and you'd have to
carry him out and it was a it'd be like
a baby mayhem and sometimes guys go this
is koto and realistic and what are the
chances of this really happening yeah
and I'd be like look if this doesn't
happen great you don't ever have to
worry about it happening for real but if
it happens you'll be ready for it at
least as ready as you can be yeah so you
get pulled off the team I got pulled off
the team and my job was gonna be to stay
with the vehicle so like basically we
were gonna drive vehicles in park the
vehicles now it was the other thing I
said I said this is dumb why why would
we leave our up-armored guns a couple
miles away mm-hmm and they said you mean
you ready for the response here you
ready oh well Dakota because we want to
go into the village clandestine you have
a 90 man Patrol yeah
just to paint a picture for everyone
basically there's a deep ravine walls on
either side at the top of the ravine it
kind of splits into two other ravines
and there's kind of villages on both
sides of that yeah it splits in two it
splits into two like it's kind of like
two valleys inside of a big valley right
and on the right-hand side was another
bad Valley but we were going in the
left-hand side when that was Gangi gone
and I mean this this terrain was built
to fight it was built to fight I mean
they had trenches in it there were
trenches in it that they used to fight
out of it's not and obviously you're
walking up the valley which means
automatically you're in the low ground
which is not where we want to be ever
all right now you the one of the guys
you're gonna be working with in the
hummers was Staff Sergeant juan
rodriguez chavez here we go back to the
book I sought out
Staff Sergeant juan Rodriguez Chavez our
Motor Transport chief I known him for
five months he didn't stand on rank and
we traded stories about growing up on
farms he had grown up on a ranch in
Mexico having a similar approach to life
rod and I had become friends he was in
the 8th grade when his family moved to
Texas were
learned english played football earned
good grades and roped cows and rodeos
our team called him hot rod
he laughed a lot bragged about how
smartest two daughters were and kept all
our vehicles in top condition Rob this
mission is [ __ ] up if the [ __ ] hits
the fan I said we're going in my team's
walking point and they'll get cut off we
have to go in and get them out and he
looked back at you devil dog rod said
say the word and I'll do the driving
yeah that's legit he's the man he's the
man and continuing on you say having
some sort of contingency plan now I walk
back to the adviser headquarters and
brief lieutenant Johnson by the way
lieutenant Johnson didn't want you out
of the team either right you wanted you
to stay with kenefick were pissed he
knew that you should be with the team if
things get hairy I said I'm coming in
rod will drive radio your coordinates
and get down to the wash [ __ ] climate
and we'll haul ass back to the main body
because they were gonna be exposed on
the far end of that wall yeah so I I so
everything that idea was planned out the
night before Chuck everything that I did
was planned out the night before and it
was all in our team I mean I told him I
mean I told him I said you know you say
the word and I'll head in there I don't
care I'm coming to get you and I mean
that we had this all planned out like
all they had to do was get to the road
and I would be there continuing on back
to the book in the talk a report about
ganja gall had come in via Brigade
internet a Special Forces team reported
that 32 fighters were moving from
Pakistan to reinforce ganja Gaul half an
hour later the video feed from an
unmanned aerial vehicle showed a man
with a mortar tube on his back entering
a known safehouse two kilometers north
of ganja golf village ten minutes later
four more men and in the same house so
you're watching this well hit so here's
the crazy part nobody told us oh so you
didn't even get that report nobody told
us
Jack um and I got a point out to
everyone I'm obviously skipping giant
chunks of this book and there's a
awesome amount of detail that that
Dakota goes into in how this is going
down and I'm kind of hitting the wave
tops to get to get the story there but
okay you don't even get that Intel but
doesn't matter because the next day I
guess where you're going into the valley
you got a guy with you named Swenson
he's in charge of some border police
some Afghan border police is that right
yeah so Swensons border police turned to
Hafez when the lights went out
Dishman he said am I saying that right
Dutchman dushman dushman dushman which
is another term for enemy for enemy
dushman
they said we must turn back so they're
already freaking out yeah yeah so they I
think I I think that they were right
some of the police had already knew they
had tipped it off yep they they had
information leaked when we were coming
in they leaked a plan yes I think that
that's why they were trying to bail out
in my opinion it was because they knew
what was already there yeah got it
and um just before 5:00 in the morning
rod and I heard gravel country crunching
on the tress so now you're actually in
position you dropped off the guys and
now the the Afghan team with some of the
advisors including team Monty are
heading up the valley and you're waiting
at the bottom and I'm sitting back at
the you know back the trucks and they're
going you know they're going into the
valley and at this point now everybody's
leaving the valley yeah this this part
just before 5:00 in the morning rod and
I heard gravel crunching on the trail
men women children sheep and goats
suddenly hurried by our trucks heading
out of the valley pre-dawn always
brought the first singsong called to
prayer followed by people scurrying
about and and this is just you knew
right then right 100% oh it's on no 110
percent
oh yeah no doubt so this you know just
for anyone that's listening that is
important to and two together here
there's a village with a bunch of
civilians in it and the civilians all
leave and they take their animals with
them they take all their they take
everything that's worth worth anything
with him
so they know that there's it's on going
back to the book as lieutenant Johnson
approached the first row of houses a
radio back to Garza that he and
Lieutenant ruler were heading toward the
house of an imam one of the village
elders seconds later an RPG streaked in
from the east followed by a burst of PKM
a russian-made machine gun that shoots a
hefty 7.62 millimeter cartridge it
started tearing up the ground in the
adobe walls as the men took cover among
the terrace walls more PKM fire came in
from the north-east joined by aks at a
closer range enemy fighters were
crouched inside the houses and below the
windows of the schoolhouse on the
Southern Ridge they were hiding in the
alleyways and dug in behind the stone
terrace walls to the east they had a
dozen fixed positions and were shooting
downhill with the Sun behind them yeah
they know what they're doing yeah this
is again deuce any kind of anybody with
any kind of military knowledge
whatsoever when you read that paragraph
for that that does two paragraphs right
there you see that you are in a horrible
horrible scenario multiple enemy
machine-gun positions in elevated
coordinated attack horrible and here's
your thoughts back to the book I waited
for the firing to die down but it didn't
the chaos of the RPG explosions PKM
machine guns aks and m16s increased I
heard the report of a recoilless rifle
basically a hundred pound shoulder or
tripod-mounted cannon at a sure sign of
a planned ambush as the dushman don't
lug that over the hills for an exercise
then I heard the clump clump of their
mortar shells there was a wide babble of
voices on the command radio advisors
yelling at each other to clear the net
no one was taking charge there was no
central command I was pacing around
frustrated being out of the fight and
not being able to help
so you've seen enough of like little
firefights that would be a little bursts
of fire and then people are gonna run
yeah I mean you know like they're gonna
just they blow their load like right in
the beginning
you know they don't have enough that
like they're not able to like us
resupply no they don't sustain anything
this was endless
and then you you mentioned this earlier
and again just to kind of point out to
people so they so they understand what
you were talking about you said hey
there's gonna be 14 different manoeuvre
elements 12 12 different maneuver
elements and they're all on the same net
now what that means is they're all in
the same radio frequency so picture this
you you're trying to have a conversation
on the phone but so are 12 other people
11 other people all trying to have a
conversation on the phone at the same
time yeah with their with their nerves
with their nerves while they're while
chaos is happening yeah and so this is
what you end up doing is actually on a
phone you have a better chance because a
phone will kind of kind of let some of
that traffic through but when you start
stepping on each other on the radio it
just cut each other off and you can't
hear anything and that's exactly what
happened and the other piece of it was
it's not just that it was all that one
frequency everything had to be relayed
through those snipers getting the
elevated high ground to get back to the
could you did you have direct coms with
the guys in the ground yes I do but I'm
saying like to get to the command so
they talk like you know and the big
thing I brought up was was you know what
happens if you're calling in a medevac
and you're calling in a call for fire
mm-hm
yeah that's that's like trying to call
the fire department and the ambulance
and you're trying to call them at the
same time like you got it you got to
separate them yeah actually that's not a
good example it's trying to call the
ambulance and an active shooter and
trying to maneuver all that stuff happen
at the same time yeah
back to the book soon both ridge lines
were sparkling with fire as the a scars
and dushman engaged each other with
rocket-propelled grenades smoke and
shrapnel filled the air
Swensen he's on this is Highlander six
he yelled over the den for the forward
line of troops pinned down at x-ray
Delta and heavy enemy fire request
immediate suppression fire kilo echo
will adjust so he's trying to call fire
your back and you and
rod says what do you think rod said if
the Dishman caught around the rear I
said and closed the backdoor they'll
catch our people in a fire sack this is
deep [ __ ] they got to get out of there
the way to break up an ambush is to
hammer it with heavy fire the Humvee
gave us armored mobility and a heavy gun
we would roll in and bring team Monty
back to the location of the command
group I grabbed the radio and called Fox
through Fox 3 lieutenant Fabio no reply
I tried Fox 6 Williams and then Fox 9
first sergeant Garza no one replied I
was calling for permission to enter the
valley asking for it from anyone who
would answer finally Fox 7 Valdez up on
the northern Ridge answered on the net
Fox 3 3 your request to enter the valley
are denied Fox 9 says you are to stay at
your present location and again I'm
throwing out a bunch of different names
here these are all the different leaders
that are out there on these different 12
elements and when you read the book for
yourself you can kind of catch and
understand exactly what was happening
there but the basically what was going
on was your call and who would ever
would answer to get permission to drive
up the valley and go give a hand yeah a
shine and get permission I put down the
handset and sat there listening as the
does as a dozen advisers try to talk
over a single radio channel it was sheer
bedlam
this is [ __ ] rod I rechecked the
ammo belt in the mark-19 rod sat in the
driver's seat
you ready rod give it a few more minutes
Meier you'll fry for this he said he was
right I'd get sent home for disobeying a
direct order there was no question in my
mind about that I was already on thin
ice with Garza Fabio and Williams so i
sat there frustrated listening to the
shooting flexing my hands on the grips
of the mark-19 and breathing hard I
tried to calm down
maybe the battle sounded worse on the
radio than it really was son of a [ __ ]
inside the Tactical Operations Center at
Joyce Oh Joyce is a couple miles away in
the Tactical Operations Center is where
they're running this they were they're
supposed to have kind of a situational
awareness of everything that's happening
and they're supposed to be able to
supply fire support so that's when we're
talking about the Tactical Operations
Center at Joyce that's what it is
captain Aaron Harding was the senior
officer on duty from midnight to 8:00 in
the morning the battle captain he had
been in Afghanistan for eight months but
had rarely controlled fires and
certainly not and certainly none like
this as artillery stood by at Joyce a
few miles away ended Asadabad a few
miles away Harding asked for more and
more information from the men on the
long table who was requesting the fire
missions was at shadow for Highlander
five for Fox three what had they heard
from Fox six who is presently in charge
the Marine advisors or the Afghan army
did the ground commander know where all
his troops were had they double-checked
the grids of the caiis he asked question
after question that Joyce 120-millimeter
was millimeter mortars were fired for
fired 15 minutes after Fabio requested
the first shell though struck within 50
metres of the enemy position the next
flurry of shells was on target that
would be the only effective fire mission
of the entire day and this is a one of
the things that you're gonna get more
into we actually recently talked about
the battle in the I drank valley and
those guys would absolutely 100% have
been overrun and what saved their ass
over and over again was artillery and
fire support now that's the biggest
advantage that we have on the
battlefield as Americans 5% and you're
caught and your team is calling for it
the advisors are calling for it and
they're not getting it yeah we're not
getting it I mean they shut it down and
to try to give the benefit of doubt here
right of why they shut it down I totally
understand it but it goes back to the
one thing I said right I mean they
couldn't probably couldn't figure out
who the hell was calling what and where
what was where I mean I don't know that
I could have confidently fired around
and but part of it was because of the
layout of everybody on one frequency you
know it goes back to the initial problem
like I don't know if I could have fired
around now am I pissed that they didn't
fire rounds absolutely like it was wrong
it was wrong for what the reasons they
did it but you know I the confusion was
so chaotic in the beginning especially
but I can tell you this that
they had got the round it a broke the
enemy mm-hmm and you know again to
advance your point of giving the benefit
of the doubt if they have no idea where
friendlies are they could have fired
rounds on friendly forces as well well
exactly and and then you know they'd
have been accountable for that and I'll
tell you that's that's a hard decision
to make to to possibly you know
fratricide blue-on-blue is in my opinion
that's the worst thing that can happen
to war and so what these guys are being
asked to possibly do is risk a
fratricide yes which in their minds and
most probably a lot of military minds I
think mine included well it's hard to
say what's better you know risk
fratricide or risk getting overrun now
if we know for a fact people are getting
overrun then you're like okay well risk
fratricide and that's why that happens
sometimes where people so I dropped that
bomb no matter what but to say I'm not a
hundred percent sure people are gonna go
overrun but I'm still gonna take the
risk of fratricide at this point that's
probably why they're holding off it is
in the beginning yeah yeah and they get
to a point where they call the
danger-close rounds and try and take
responsibility and what will get there
back to the book the enemy above the
enemy above worked their way around the
edges of the valley shooting downhill
the Taliban machine gunners tracked in
on one a scar then another then another
it was a killing ground they're all over
the place Swenson was thinking to
himself I may not make it out of here if
you hunker down and don't shoot back you
will surely die the other side gains
confidence and rushes forward in the
frenzy of combat soldiers act like
sharks they sense weakness and circle in
picking off the wounded and the
defenseless slowly the dushman were
closing in from both sides of the wash
so they were ready let me tell you
something they were good they were good
they were trained that gear you know
they had they had plate carriers they're
taking the uniforms off our dead guys
you know they put Kevlar zon should
they're good still trying to get fire
support here Swenson an identified enemy
position two four grid positions there
are two basic ways of calling in
artillery you can give the grid
coordinates of the target or the kilo
echo number for a grid and adjust after
the initial round or you can give your
own location and a compass bearing to
the end distant to the target the second
technique is called a polar mission
provides the guns with the locations of
both the friendly observer and the
target tell the talk I'll send it polar
Swenson radioed to Kaplan it's on me
give them my initials I'm making the
decision not them assuming accurate fire
the u.s. mortars were less than two
miles away the only target endangered by
the polar plot was the enemy by sending
his initial Swenson was taking full
responsibility if anything went wrong if
a friendly soldier or civilian were hit
the burden rested squarely on Swenson
not with the talk in the rear the talk
responded to the polar request by asking
again for information that was
impossible to provide where were all the
friendly troops what was the forward
line of trace of the friendly units was
everyone accounted for were any
civilians endangered Kaplan told shadow
the relay team above the him tell the
talk that's that it's critical I repeat
critical we have advisors pinned down
the talk denied shadows fire mission
furious sergeant summers at shadow 4
pressed back against the talk the main
element is being hit from the north east
and south all elements are engaged I
repeat all elements are heavily engaged
we need fire missions now the NCOs
inside the talk were doing their job and
the artillery and mortar crews wanted to
oblige yet it seemed to sergeant Somers
that every time he related a fire
mission the talk asked him 20 questions
a second string was running the show
here and not well in firefights it's not
unusual for 200 to 2,000 artillery
shells to be fired over the course of
the first hour of the Battle of Ganjgal
when men lay trapped and dying the taça
Joyce allowed only 21 artillery shells
to be fired
since World War two forward observers
had received artillery fire under the
rule of silence is consent when an
observer called for fire the mission
went by radio to the Operations Center
and to the guns silenced by the ops
center constituted consent for the guns
to fire in the 21st century with
computers making instant firing
calculations within two minutes shells
could be hitting the target but
beginning about 2006 sergeants and
lieutenants on the front lines were
trusted less the High Command believed
the grunts were too quick to call and
fires that endangered civilians
resulting in an embittered population
that supported the insurgency the
solution was to apply a strict new rule
two months before ganja gaulle General
Stanley McChrystal the senior commander
in Afghanistan issued a directive that
forbade the use of artillery against or
near any structure likely to contain
civilians unless the higher the next
higher headquarters commander had
approved that ended silences consent the
High Command had shifted decision-making
from the battlefield to the staff
Swenson was not trusted to make the hard
decisions instead officers in the talk
with a confused idea of the battlefield
had to decide whether to honor his
requests for fire yeah in it so that's
where my problem comes in right you know
if the doctrine is that you I give my
initials I take the responsibility well
then follow the doctrine yeah you know
that's there's there's where they went
wrong in and I'll tell you something
else that you know you talked about how
confusing it was over the net and
clearly it was obviously very confusing
how long would it take to verbally
explain the layout of this whole
situation it would take a very long time
oh it would take an extremely eloquent
person who had the time to kind of
compose himself and and and sit there
and try and explain it that's why you
make K kilo echoes that's why you have
these pre-planned fire positions so that
you don't have to think anymore if we
can direct fire
and and what instead of having to
communicate what the situation on the
ground is what you communicate is this
is what we need and this is where you
need to put it yeah I mean that's 100%
innit I mean that's 100% it is you know
you could never first off you could
never relay all the information there
and guess what and at the end of day it
was irrelevant to what they were needing
yeah and also by the time you if you
could relay it by the time you laid it
it would be different cuz what are you
gonna tell everyone to sit still for a
minute while I explain where you are
that doesn't work that's why that's why
decentralized command is so important on
the battlefield this is the exact reason
why decentralized command is so
important on the battlefield when you
centralize command people people that
actually are there that need to be able
to make decisions make things happen
can't do it yeah and by the way how do
you overcome a situation like this how
do you overcome a situation where okay
you're my subordinate yeah you work for
me and I don't I don't want you to be
able to have the ability to fire because
I'm afraid you're gonna hurt civilians
how do I solve that the way to solve it
is not to say no I don't get that you
that Authority the way I solve it as
they say okay Dakota let me explain some
things to you we need to protect the
civilian populace we need to make sure
we don't damage any infrastructure to
the best of our ability I want you to
understand how strategically important
that is do you understand let me put you
through some scenarios what if you were
here and this happened what would you do
what if you're here and this happened
what would you do I trained you and I
build trust so that I can decentralize
the command that's how you overcome it
you don't overcome it it's a shortcut to
try and centralize and it ends up
getting people killed all right
going back to the book Fox 31 lieutenant
Johnson finally came up on the radio
were pinned down in a house receiving
accurate fire from the next house we
have to get out of here he was cut off
by others pushing to use the same
frequency three or four advisers were
trying to talk stepping on each other I
could hear the strain and their voices
the lack of crisp orders the frantic
yelling of men who were pinned down
after a few minutes Fox 3 to staff
sergeant kenefick tried to pass his
location on the grid to Fabio I can't
shoot back Aaron said because I'm pinned
down they're shooting at me from the
house it's so close grid 3 2 this is 3 3
radio staff sergeant kenefick repeat
your grid repeat your grid or you you
radioed to kenefick repeat your grid
repeat your grid so he faded as he was
trying to tell you his grid nothing
after that but static and garbled voices
that broke it from me I had promised my
team I would be there as far as I was
concerned my command element wasn't in
command
twice I had heard shadow say that air
would be on station in 15 minutes
nothing happened
how long do you do nothing while your
friends are fighting for their lives Fox
7 this is 3/3 sitting here as stupid
we're going in rod and I were on the net
with Valdes there was no dispute among
us it was about zero 600 time to move
I was the vehicle commander so the fault
lay with me for disobeying orders if I
arrived in the valley and discovered
that the command group had had the
situation under control I knew there was
a good chance I'd be sent back to the
States and disgrace when I shouted the
ass cars to follow us they look confused
up on the north outpost Valdez grabbed a
senior Afghan sergeant the sergeant
radio to the Afghan drivers clustered
around our truck urging them and pash to
to follow me mortar shells were falling
a football field away to our West the
enemy knew our trucks were somewhere on
the path but uncertain just where the
explosions made my made the ass cars
jumpy just the same some of them jumped
into two Humvees and roared in the
position behind us rod let's go I said
he put it in gear now by that time you
start actually going into the valley and
as you're going in by that time several
ass cars were stumbling out of the
battlefield some bleeding a few without
their rifles all exhausted
we're americani I yelled dose dosed the
ass cars pointed up toward the village
so as you're driving in you're seeing
guys fleeing the battlefield I mean it
was like it was terrible like as we go
in you you're just seeing these guys
come out it's in Ramadan so they won't
eat or they won't drink any water and
they're coming out this battle and
they're just like you're not even close
to the valley yet and they're coming
honest battle they don't have any
weapons on them they're just broken
they're bloodied they're they're been
shot they've just I mean you're carrying
each other and you're just like what are
we going into
somewhere behind us was a US army
platoon it seemed to me to be a time for
them to make a move they were the Quick
Reaction Force our insurance policy
Valdez was on the radio arguing with dog
three six the quick-reaction army
platoon commander dog three six this is
Fox 7 Valdez radio radioed you need to
get in there man Fox 3 threes to your
front and a Humvee drive east until you
link up with them Fox 7 this is dog 3 6
at the lieutenant our vehicles are too
big for the mission we were driving on a
footpath I was barely wide enough for
our Humvee Valdez came up with an
alternative dog 3 6 this is Fox 7
I understand drive forward until you
reach the Afghan vehicles use them to
get into the fight there are people out
there dying the platoon leader said he
had to wait for clearance from the talk
at Joyce yeah what kind of vehicles did
the QRF a Iranian Maps okay god I mean
excuse yeah how awesome would it be to
have an MRAP roll under this situation
yeah I don't think they could have the
road wouldn't children too small yeah
because they ended up coming in in one
of those it looks like a tank but it's
on wheels mm-hmm
and it ended up flipping over often off
the bank but they look at the end of the
day we had a ton of Humvees I mean we
just brought in 90 people mmm
sitting right there they could have
jumped in on these and came the
helicopter ops center called back saying
the retasking of the birds had been
cancelled because Lance had not called
his own brigade headquarters to ask
permission and because another mission
from north of Ganjgal
was of higher priority so one of the
guys in the in the ops center had
actually said you know what screw it I'm
calling for Carlos and but he hadn't
called the brigade and run through the
proper chain of command and they they
shut him down yeah
so here we go more than an hour into the
fight the situation was as follows
team Monty was trapped in a house in the
US and Afghan commanders were pinned
down by shooters closing in on them from
three sides the north and south
observation posts were under fire the
ass cars were caught in the open with
nowhere to hide
rod and I hadn't reached the wash the 1
3 2 Quick Reaction platoon was not quick
reacting the talk at Joyce was paralyzed
preventing artillery support and the
helicopter gunships had not arrived it
was the perfect storm
that's just um there's absolutely
there's nothing else go wrong right now
it's a perfect storm it is the absolute
perfect storm Swenson wanted a massive
artillery barrage because the douche men
didn't have overhead cover artillery air
bursts would send millions of lancets
raining down toward them hundreds of
shells had to shake the mountains and
roll thunder down the valley the dushman
were zealots but they weren't crazy once
artillery began exploding overhead gunmo
if a Ches wouldn't get up and run
forward in the open yet the talk refused
to fire Ganjgal only a few miles from
camp joyce unleashing a barrage in your
own backyard wouldn't win the applause
at higher headquarters the directive
from the high command was so clear do
not employ air-to-ground or indirect
fires against residential compounds
defined as any structure or building
known or likely to contain civilians
unless the Ground Force commander has
verified that no civilians are present
terrible and I mean you know and there's
that you know that rule right there is
written so impossible you know what do
you do you mean you the village you're
getting shot so you run through there
you civilian or you shoot at me you know
um I have to look do like a full review
of the RO ease or the specific tour
directive but you know normally the
self-defense thing trumps everything
well usually and that's what I always
say right I always talk about ro ease
and you know ro ease will say you know
blah blah blah blah blah
living at the end of it it always ends
it says or hostile act hostile intent
mhm but it's all by interpretation I
mean that it goes back to the commanders
I mean you know I don't blame the ro way
that Stanley McChrystal put in place for
what happened that day I blame the
people the leadership who was
incompetent to make a decision you know
I mean like like it's like nobody wants
to just own it and take accountability
and take responsibility so you know what
I'm doing this because it's the right
thing to do they want to be able to say
well I didn't do it because well this is
the order mmm
come on come on you know if you're in a
leadership position take take
responsibility yeah you got to do the
right thing that's the bottom line and
that's what makes leadership hard and
sometimes the right thing is to break
rules sometimes the right thing is to
not follow orders sometimes orders are
wrong and you shouldn't follow them and
Napoleon said if you if you're in charge
and you get tasked with something that's
wrong and you execute it you're culpable
doesn't matter if you get ordered or not
sometimes you break the rules going
right back to the yes-man thing right
and I guarantee I guarantee the intent
of Stan McChrystal putting this are we
in place wasn't to deny guys that were
pinned down by enemy fire but again how
are we communicating it you know we put
in so we put in the
for our priorities in place correctly so
that everybody knows yeah I mean you
know when it's put out in an email it's
kind of like it's as dangerous as you
interpreting me a text mm-hmm I mean
everybody looks at different yep and you
know what that's why things like
commander's intent are so important if I
know what it is like your I know if I
know what it is that you want done and
my job is to get it done and you give me
parameters to do it within I'll stay
within those parameters and I'll get the
job done and I'll come back to you know
say hey boss I had to I had to bend the
rules a little bit here but I got the
mission done or I might call you back
and say hey I'm getting ready to break
the rules to get the mission done do you
want me to break him or not yeah all
right back to the book shadow the Army
outpost on the Southern Ridge replied
that the talk at Joyce said that fire
mission was too close to the village too
close to the village lieutenant Johnson
said if you don't give me these rounds
right now I'm gonna die try your best
shadow replied knowing the talk wouldn't
fire try your best try your best from
the tone of shadows voice I knew he was
on the verge of complete rage he wanted
to strangle the officers in the talk and
Joyce I felt the same way this couldn't
be happening we were on the same side
we weren't Marines or soldiers we
weren't Americans or ass cars we were
one lone group fighting desperately to
stay alive the villages with villagers
weren't our friends this was a war and
my team was on the verge of dying whose
side was the talk on radio call after
radio call Swenson kept requesting smoke
finally around 0 6:30 the talk at Joyce
permitted for white phosphorus
phosphorus rounds to be fired into the
southeast back side of the village too
far away to conceal my team
those were the last rounds fired during
the battle at about zero 640 the talk at
Joyce forbade any more artillery support
sighting garbled communications
incomplete calls for fire procedures and
a lack of situational awareness on the
part of those trapped in the valley so
there's the there's the reasons from
their perspective garbled communications
incomplete calls for fire procedures and
a lack of situational awareness on the
part of those trapped in the valley
meanwhile during this time you've been
moving up grabbing bodies coming back
and here we go again as we move forward
for a third time the talk had finally
ordered the army platoon dog 3/2 to move
forward they pulled him behind us with
the platoon leader and a Humvee with an
anti-tank tow missile on the roof the
tow made no sense to me but the truck
was equipped with a 240 machine gun
behind them were 20 US soldiers and for
hemily heavily armoured vehicles you
rollin with me lieutenant
I was confirming what I took for granted
I'll scout the route first before I
bring my platoon in the terrain may be
too tough he refused to put his soldiers
into the Afghan vehicles I could
understand that okay I go first I said
you cover our six the Afghans will be
behind you as we bounced forward I heard
team Monti again come up on the radio
we're under fire lieutenant Johnson said
we're surrounded somehow you're heading
back in yeah yeah and I am and my whole
goal is just to get them you know was to
get them to the road and yeah I mean
that that was their goal I could get to
the road they could give me the vehicles
we're good so I was trying to push I
thought that they had took over a house
right I thought they had pushed into the
village and took over a stone 42 house
and that's what I thought they had done
and I lost I lost communications with
them so I thought they had done you know
when kenefick was trying to give that
grid I was trying to write it down
because I knew if I could get that grid
I'd know where they were had I could
plot it I could be there and go get them
and you know the one part I don't talk
about in there is probably the hardest
parts the whole deal is is that the
first trip that I made in I was probably
70 60 to 70 meters from there still
alive
so you're in the valley now you're with
a group of guys going back to the book
here a bullet had entered Westbrook's
neck near the shoulder blade and
ricocheted downward a day got dangerous
but not fatal wound Swenson applied
quick claw powder and a bandage to seal
off the bleeding the fight had been
raging for over 90 minutes in the chain
of command throughout Kunar province was
on alert
procedures for releasing helicopters had
been installed in two oh-58 kiowa x'
were in route to the valley at zero 7:15
they'd contacted Swenson Highlander this
is pale horse the PC pilot command
radioed what do you need pale horse
Swenson replied I am under heavy fire
from the village and the hills to the
east and on both sides request immediate
suppression while we pulled back the
Kiowa squadron had been in Kunar for ten
months
the pilots knew the terrain and the
enemy habits they intended to swoop in
low and criss-crossing strafing room
runs deliberately swerving and cutting
back in odd angles they didn't care
whether they hit the dushman they wanted
to force them to crouch down and cease
firing
the aerial tactics would allow the
command group to pull back westward to
draw down under under reduced enemy
pressure as Swenson moved he called for
a medevac shadow radioed back to that
the TOC wanted questions answered before
calling for one is he army or marine
shadow said Swenson cursed Maj Williams
was more diplomatic
this is Fox 6 Williams radioed it
doesn't matter his service he's us there
was a pause then shadow reluctantly
radioed repeat talk needs to know if
he's army or marine it's in the
regulations yeah it was
you get a guy calling for medevac and
you're getting a house today is the
person that needs to ease the casualty
army or Marine Corps yeah and it really
didn't matter to him
it really did matter to them oh you're
saying it mattered I'm saying it to who
was asking they really their decisions
were based off of who it was all right
at this point you're you're you you I
think you're you going back and forth
going back in the valley getting bodies
helping wounded coming back out you're
under fire the whole time rod is getting
after it with you sometimes you have
some us people with you sometimes you
don't and again these are things you
have to buy this book and to get these
details out of it and read it so you
understand the full magnitude of what
we're talking about here going back to
the book huh Fez left the command group
to sort itself out helping a wounded a
scar was headed back west to the
operational release point when I had
stopped them I need you to come back in
with me I can't find them without you I
said hah Fez was married recently he was
wounded and exhausted he could now go
home than have a life if today is my
time to die then I die
so he's rolling with you he had he
rolled with me the whole time
again to all those people out there that
well I guess I should just say for the
people out there that have a hard time
understanding what's going on overseas
you know here's an Afghan soldier that
is now gonna risk his life to help an
American Marine go and find his friends
yeah because we were brothers
going back to the book shortly after we
had again down the valley we bumped into
another group of rent wounded ass cars
rod recognized the first sergeant who
was dripping blood down the right side
of his trousers he was waving his arms
begging us to stop for a scars hobbled
over and threw themselves in the
backseat splashing blood all over the
place we drove them back to the
collection point the first sergeant was
blubbering beg begging us not to go back
in I was a little rough shoving him out
of the truck I was running out of time
and patience once we dropped them off we
gunned it back down the track we were
getting to a place where we couldn't
turn around and couldn't dodge and weave
the arm as the RPG smoke trails came out
us we could get pretty stuck in here rod
yelled the truck had very little
traction and absolutely no cover then I
guess we'll die with them I yelled back
what else could I say
so we weren't going back rod shifted
into low gear and we bounced forward you
I noticed this throughout the book you
have a hard time like any time you saw
wounded guys you were like all right
well we got to make another trip now we
got to make another trip even with those
wounded Afghan guys like you want to go
help you guys but at the same time you
see these guys here car get in the truck
and we'll take these guys back got a big
heart bro
got a big heart I mean look you know I
didn't just lose I didn't just lose four
guys that day I lost 10 guys cuz I lost
six Afghans I lost 10 brothers you don't
I mean I mean those guys were just as
close to me my Afghans were just as
close to me as any Marines I reserved
with
and that's why they're joining you to go
back in there and fight that's why I'm
live today I mean that's that's the
relationships that I had with them and
the Brotherhood that I had for them with
them is why I'm alive today I mean they
they are incredible human beings so
you're driving around in here
back to the book only rods skill at the
wheel was preventing me from being hit
again and again bullets make different
sounds when they pass by you the cracks
of bullets breaking the sound barrier
meaning they're high maybe five or ten
feet over your head the bullets that
snap close by your ears are the real
killers a few losing power and slowing
down made a low buzzing sound strange
though it may seem I wasn't scared or
angry I was beyond that I didn't think I
was going to die I knew I was dead there
wasn't anything I could do about it I
wasn't a thinking human being I had gone
elsewhere I wasn't firing the machine
gun I was the machine gun rod wasn't
driving the truck rod was the truck
I had melded with my weapon I was no
more human than a five-foot machine gun
I was embracing we were locked together
metal and flesh without that 50 Cal I
would have quivered like the a scars
helpless in the storm but with that
weapon
I felt transported I had something to do
until the blackness came yeah I just
kept I kept like the bullets were
hitting inside the turret they had
elevation on us and so they were hitting
inside the turret and man you could hear
them coming by and I just I remember
sitting there you know cuz if you get
down I mean you know you know your your
instinct is to duck down the turret but
you do that they'll overrun you I mean
they were running at the truck so yep
you duck down there full sprint and
you're never gonna come back up you know
what I mean and I just kept waiting for
a bullet I just knew it was gonna hit me
in the face
I just kept waiting for a bullet to hit
me lights out
like I just I just there was no doubt in
my mind that I was gonna die
zero zero to help but I was gonna make
this son of a [ __ ] earn it they had
it to do check I wasn't paying attention
to the Afghan soldiers rod and I plan to
keep driving east until we obliterated
until we were obliterated or we found my
team suddenly with no warning five or
six ass cars who were lying in a
terrorist's about a 100 meters away left
up and raced towards our truck when was
one was shot back and pitched forward
Wham a second man went down screaming
Wham a third then a fourth and a fifth
I'd never seen anything like it five men
down in five seconds there was so much
screeching and shooting that I could
couldn't pick out the location of the
weapon that had shot them to deliver
such lethal grazing fire the machine
gunner must have been hidden only a few
hundred meters away with a clear line of
sight in his bipod firmly anchored yet
whoever shot those men didn't raise his
gun sights and stitch me I knew he was
looking at me but I couldn't see him
there was nothing I could do he let me
live not one of his rounds even struck
our truck I can't explain it we used to
call the trucks bullet magnets they are
I mean it's like the rapists target and
a freaking you're the turret gunner
you're like the icing on the cake you're
the check the cherry on the icing on the
cake yeah cuz that truck gets over if
they take the gun out that truck doesn't
come out of there no silver ring oh hell
yeah yeah but you know even though it's
a bullet magnet I mean you know just
like right there I think that kind of
paints the picture I mean it's the it's
the only chance you have right I mean
you you're out I mean that's how dialed
in they are it's it's I mean I was
literally watching guys people throw the
term miracle around all the time like
the fact that you right here there's
five guys within you know the spitting
distance from you and they all go down
and you're the the most prime target
and you don't get job in you want to
talk about helpless the most helpless
feeling you got is watching guys trying
to get to you and just getting mowed
down I mean you want to talk about
helpless and you don't even know where
it's coming from I mean you want talk
about helpless is watching another human
being run directly at you to get help
and you're just watching them just go
down one after the other after the other
can you imagine that dude yeah it's just
a you know it's it
they were good that day you get this
call from Valdez they're coming at you I
can see them closing from both sides
they're swarming you know in front of
our truck I saw a few guys sprinting
across the wasps from left to right
heads low I don't think they saw us
coming up behind them or if they heard
the truck engine over the din of the
gunfire they scurried too quickly for me
to get off a burst glancing to my right
I'd looked smack into the eyes of five
or six men in dirty man dresses crouched
alongside a drainage ditch not ten
meters away when I gate with them they
ducked down like they were playing
hide-and-seek it took me a few seconds
to realize that they were spreading out
to seal off the open end of the
horseshoe valley zip locking the frozen
ass cars inside a fire sack rod and I
had blundered into their rear so they
were about to they're about to surround
every Sunday that's what they were doing
there was a trench and they were closing
it they're closing the gate and and we
that truck you happen to be there to be
right in it no fire sac is a is a
doctrinal term actually which means
you're surrounded and they're going to
shoot into the sack and kill everyone no
we were bouncing over the rocks no
faster than a man can run when a bearded
dushman clutching an ache a left out of
a ditch and sprinted after us like a man
trying to catch his catch a bus my gun
almost wouldn't swivel low enough to
shoot him the barrel was tilted down as
far as it could go
I fired into his chest and he went down
like he'd hit a glass wall
the bullet doesn't blow a man back like
in the movies either he stumbles or on
or he falls dead this man fault fell
dead rod was yelling at me maybe I was
hypnotized for a second by the Deaf
there was a guy trying to open the right
door I couldn't depress the 50 Cal that
low I can't get him I yelled the gun
won't go down low enough it takes the
brain 12 thousands of a second to react
to danger
my mind was a complete blank I had fired
so many thousands of rounds that I
didn't think what I was doing once
you've practiced emotion long enough it
becomes second nature
some Reacher's researchers call it
expertise induced amnesia athletes call
it being in the zone
I call it self-preservation I grabbed my
m4 leaned out and shot the guy four or
five times in the shoulder and neck it
was like shooting a zombie
there was no shock power in the little
five five six millimeter bullets he fell
to the ground I pivoted back to the 50
Cal and grabbed the Spade handle the
weapon my hands and my eyes were working
as a trained unit independent of my
brain man sight picture shoot man sight
picture shoot you don't really look at
the target the enemy remains out of
focus you concentrate on the sight
picture man sight picture shoot I hit
one or two guys next to the truck and
the others duck back into the ditch
Valdez came back on the radio rod watch
her front rod was focused on keeping
traction in the loose gravel if the
truck got stuck even for a moment we'd
be toast he looked ahead to see a
bearded hatless man in his mid 30s
dressed in a brick red man jams with a
green chest rig full of ammo running
toward the truck and firing an 8k at us
from the hip hold on homey rod yelled he
hit the accelerator the truck hit the
man squarely in the chest there was a
bump and then another bump under the
tires holy [ __ ] rot rod yelled I just
ran over a guy back up and do it again
I'd been shot in the elbow a bleeder
that did no real damage the bone was
fine in a fight adrenaline deadens the
pain I did a little rapping and got back
to shooting the more [ __ ] up things
got the more rod and I started laughing
he was steering away from RPG streaming
at us and
laughing and I was shooting the big gun
and laughing definitely crazy but your
emotions have to go somewhere the enemy
fire slacking Donna says the Chi was
darted around they were like a steel
umbrella over us a few minutes later
pale horse came back on my net three
three were Winchester we'll be back in
15 Mike's Winchester meant they had
expended all their ammunition they were
too late to carry much and they've been
shooting at targets wherever they looked
the firing picked up we were again the
pinata I climbed down from the turret
and talked to talk to Rodman Hafez we
had started with six ammo cans we are
now down to one I had fired more than
2,000 rounds guys we need a new gun I
said it was three steps forward two
steps back as we turned I saw a NASCAR
free crawling feebly toward the road we
stopped and I hopped out a PKM machine
gun was tailing the ground around me so
I dodged back and forth until I reached
him one Kiowa out of ammo hovered above
me and distracted the enemy ignoring the
RPG shells exploding in the air I turned
the ass car onto his back hit by three
rounds in his upper chest and neck he
was gurgling and drowning in his own
blood I rolled him onto his side and he
died before I could pick him up
yeah like you can see I kind of circle
things that are gonna read yeah and I
just was like circling giant chunks yeah
- so people can understand what I mean I
know that people aren't gonna understand
really the the kind of chronological
evolution and maybe the mechanics of
what was happening but I want people at
least to understand until they read this
book themselves the freaking situation
that you were in which was beyond mayhem
yeah you know you talk about training
like to the worst case scenario I always
had done the same thing and this was
worse than any worst-case scenario that
I could have ever ever dreamed up of
I've ever been in it was the worst of
any situation I could have never sit
here and you said give me the worst
thing you could just come up with and I
could have never done it I could have
never I could have never done it of just
I mean you just I mean it's just like I
mean I just felt like everybody was
dying like I mean it was just I mean
there were like literally there were
bodies everywhere I mean it you couldn't
turn around and look and there not be a
body somewhere
and you just pretty much figured you
were gonna be joining them soon enough
no I did I mean there was no doubt there
was no doubt in my mind I wasn't making
it out there and you know I walked in
that day this just shows you how
ignorant I was like when you talk about
your buddy who was kind of like puffs
the chest up right I had that was me
mm-hmm
I literally I'm I'm gonna tell you I'm
gonna just tell you how ignorant I was I
walked in that day and I and I there was
not a situation that I was ever gonna
see that I couldn't get us out of there
wasn't one there wasn't one and it was
like you know it was like God showing me
just how small it was
you know you got take I mean these these
Afghan soldiers I mean they're my
buddies you know and part of the problem
was how long in the deployment was this
supposed to been nine months and how all
this when did this happen about they got
there in July August September yeah so
this is like three months of deployment
yeah and part of the problem was we just
done the NATO transition and they were
using weapon systems that they weren't
used to that shoot too small around yeah
yeah a lot but they weren't used to
these weapons they weren't even used to
enforce em hmm
I mean an m4 is are so much more fickle
m16s ever six things are said well even
more so than m4 him some scenes are so
much more fickle than an 8k they must
have been cursing them damn it 16 oh
they they were I mean they were oh yeah
I mean they you know that they would
have something go wrong and they would
just drop the magazine I mean I mean
they were just yeah so they're so like
like I'm telling you if you say
everything like we had just so we just
hit Ramadan so none of them were
drinking water none of them were eating
we had just I mean you look at every
factor of this it was the perfect storm
we just transitioned this is the first
mission first or second mission that
we'd ever went on with all NATO weapons
I mean you look at all these factors and
it was it was perfect
had you ever worked with the QRF before
no not that one I was used to the ones
you know up near where we were at but
you got it done no interoperability with
those guys before no and they got shut
down so after the talk learned that it
was Marines they got shut down all
support stopped all sports soft
all right sometimes I got nothing to say
and that's one of them I didn't even
comprehend that yeah all right we're
going back to the book we turned left
out of the wash onto the narrow track
back to the casualty collection point I
looked around for major Williams he was
sitting off to one side wounded in in
shock there were four or five vehicles
in at least 20 ass cars milling around
these were our Afghans we had come down
from Monte together I glanced hopefully
from the group from group to group hafez
was asking if they'd seen lieutenant
Johnson they say lieutenant is back in
ganja God said if I said the team didn't
make it out [ __ ] somewhere farther up
the wash my team was fighting to stay
alive I'd promised to get them and rod
and I had the only gun truck willing to
enable to go in I climbed down from the
turret and ran over to the ass car he'd
taken a bullet in the fine he was slowly
bleeding out I kept a stack of
tourniquets in my med pack and knew how
to apply them I wrapped the tourniquet
around his thigh in my frustration I
twisted it extra tight and he screamed
how fast tell him to shut up I said
hurting is better than dying if you're a
grunt you'll come face to face with
horrendous gore you have to steel
yourself to seeing mangled bodies and
smelling blood doctors and nurses cope
with screaming and suffering every day I
had dressed out dozens of deer you
learned to disassociate from the task
when you're pulling out warm guts are
cutting off slabs of dripping meat with
the blood sticking to your hands he went
through something like 15 tourniquets at
least quite a few files is morphine a
couple need needle decompression MPA is
quite a few amperes nasals
the quiet
nakaya's had rearmed and come back on
station directing us toward another
wounded like it or not we had been
pressed into ambulance business the
Kiowa commanded by Chief Warrant Officer
Yossarian Solano a good name for a guy
in a crazy war had been a Marine grunt
before becoming an army pilot his bird
was easy to talk to and he directed me
where to go sometimes hovering so low I
could just about reach up and touch his
skids he was covering my rear area when
I got out of the truck
the pilots were fearless knowing my team
was lost they were running search
patterns 20 feet off the ground so they
could identify each body damn yeah I
mean and he did that like you know they
were so his commander he was having
problems with his commander and the guy
who was leading those birds you know
because they fly into birds and so the
but when I told him that it was Marines
missing he dropped down and covered me
the whole time you ever meet him yeah
yeah he's incredible I just seen him
seen him like around Thanksgiving mm-hmm
he is an incredible human being just so
everyone knows like just cuz you're in a
helicopter does not make you safe at all
especially a Kiowa like maybe you're a
little bit safer in Apache cuz you got
some armor no how much how much armors
in a Kiowa zero right they play little
and I don't know how many his bird was
shot to [ __ ] no kidding yeah yeah yeah
it was shot to pieces
I climbed up a terrace wall and followed
the contours of the field around the
corner to find a body lying face down on
the man's hands were green gloves with
the fingers cut I knew before I even
rolled him over that it was da dolly my
closest afghan friend he was due to take
leave in a few weeks he had left on Brad
terms with his mother who was sure he
would be killed finally after two years
she had relented and invited him back to
the farm for a visit he'd been hit in
the face when I looked at his dull eyes
I lost my concentration and knelt there
for a moment oblivious he was a little
guy too small for his body armor he and
I had rigged up two tourniquets to hold
the body armor in place close to his
chest I knelt down to untie the
tourniquets I needed them for other guys
and I needed to get the heavy armor off
him so I could carry him to the truck if
I felt a tap as something hit my left
shoulder it didn't register at first it
was like I'd been hit with a light stone
I glanced up to see a tough-looking
Afghan with a long black beard Glac
glaring down at me he was wearing a
dirty gray man dressed a flak jacket and
an Afghan army helmet he was pointing a
k' at my head
gesturing for me to stand up in broken
English he was telling me to drop my
rifle come he said waving the barrel of
his a k in my face I couldn't believe
that I'd screwed up so badly all I could
think of was that my head would be sawed
off and held up on TV no way I died
right where I was right now I had been
dead for a few hours anyways the
borrowed time was up that's all my rifle
was resting on my left thigh pointing in
his direction the stubby grenade
launcher was attached to the underside
of the barrel I raised one arm like I
was going to surrender and pulled the
trigger of the launcher with my free
thumb the 40 millimeter grenade shop for
two feet - his armored vest it didn't
explode
instead it knocked him back stunned him
with the with the breath
slammed out of him he staggered back and
fell on his side for a few seconds I
thought the blow had killed him
no such luck I pushed myself erect as I
push myself erect he drew in a big
breath and stirred I kicked at his face
losing my balance and falling on top of
him we were both on the ground wrestling
Afghan tribesmen will have legs like
steel from climbing mountains all day
all their lives so I had to keep his
legs off me I pinned his elbows and
blocked his reach for his a.k I was
pushing my helmeted head into his chest
so he couldn't gouge in my eyes any
second I figured that grenade would
explode and both of us could stop
worrying about any of this that pawed
the ground with my right hand and found
a rock the size of a baseball I clutched
it and swung by blindly at his face the
blow stunned him before he could recover
I pushed off off of his chest lifted the
rock high in my right fist and smashed
it down like a hammer breaking his front
teeth he looked me in the eyes the fight
knocked out of him his head not moving
we both knew it was over I drew back my
arm and drove the stone down crushing
his left cheekbone
he went limp I pushed up on my knees and
I hit him with more force the blow caved
in the left side of his forehead I
smashed his face again and again driven
by pure animal rage
that's close combat obviously when
you're killing another human being with
a rock yeah yeah it's real you know I
just I just remember his face you know
and I mean look God let me just state
this up front first off I feel no
remorse at all but I think it was it it
was at that at that point to wear a
humanized it that makes sense I get
humanized the fact of taking another
person's life like I'll remember the
look in his eyes when he knew he was
gonna die and at that point like you
know I obviously I didn't think of it
then but you know when I still see that
face I still think about you know he was
the father there was somebody at home
that wanted him to come home just as bad
as somebody wanted me to come home you
know whether you agree with his beliefs
or not people don't agree with their
beliefs and you know but the end of the
day he believed in his beliefs just as
much as I did
we're both human beings we're both
fighting for a cause that neither one of
us can see that we both just believe in
and it had to be one of us and my guess
is and you can maybe I'm wrong but my
guess is the reason he didn't just
straight kill you is because he had you
had the drop on you
yeah and and and having you as a trophy
in an orange jumpsuit would have would
have been much more impactful for him
and their cause yeah I mean he could
have easily it would have took him no
time to get me across the border we were
right on the border that's what he would
have done he woulda took me across the
border you sold me and he would have
been a hero he had probably been
promoted whatever you know network he
was in I mean he would have been the man
and I was worth a lot more to him alive
than I was dead you know but but then on
the backside I mean I've questioned it
so many times like you know was it that
or was it maybe him maybe he was trying
to bluff me didn't have bullets me I
don't know
I don't I don't know like and you know
there's so many times in this whole
battle that I just wonder like like why
why not me
you know I mean war and I guess you
could apply us all life but it becomes
very clear at war it's like inches
millimeters you know what what you sure
you could say you got missed by by
around by a foot a couple inches but
when you take that back to a person's
weapon you got missed by a millimeter
millimeter of aim that's what it is you
could have got you you could have got
missed by a gust of wind mm-hmm
literally you could have you could have
been missed by the wind picking up so
while all that's going on back to the
book Highlander was the radio call sign
for captain swenson he was trying to
gather reinforcements he pulled aside
the lieutenant in charge of the Quick
Reaction Platoon mount up Swensons and
told him you're no help back here we
need your firepower
I can't lieutenant said the TOC says
were to cover the vehicles Swenson
grabbed the glue tenets 50 watt radio
called the Joyce the talk told the
platoon to move into the valley Swenson
Fabio rod and Hafez then hopped into an
undamaged Humvee to drive back in but
the platoon did not follow instead the
platoon leader again called back to
Joyce and somehow received permission to
remain in the rear out of the fight yeah
it was frustrating
it was frustrating it was frustrating
that you know I I met that guy a few
years ago we ran into that we were in
the same meeting it was frustrating
every bit of it was frustrating it was
so I mean every single bit of it was
unnecessary and frustrating back to the
book I started the day with 14 or 16
tourniquets I used them all I put four
on one guy who'd lost his left arm and
his left leg below the knee he survived
one a scar shot in the neck sounded like
he was slurping through a straw there
was nothing I could do except listen to
him strangled to death
at one point 2 ft f-15s roared low
through the valley opening their
afterburners to create a hell of a
lion's roar the pilots wouldn't drop any
bombs yeah I mean you know usually but
but at this point you know the only show
of force ever works is I mean they had
so much momentum at this time I mean it
was like momentum right so it started
out as fighters like his fighters that
came across the border and then what it
turned into was when they seen that we
weren't getting the support and when we
they seemed that we weren't getting
control of the situation and fires
weren't coming they escalated in they
gained momentum what everybody else
joined in you take so you had the guys
that showed up to fight and then you
have the opportunist of the villagers
that turn into fighters instantly
because they have the upper hand and so
they start gaining momentum of more
people fighting you every single minute
because I was like I do is pick up the
gun off the dead person you know
literally I mean there were literally
women running through the village with
like these bowls and you know you look
at him you know well all right that you
know she's just a woman with the ball
running rocket comes in she drops a bowl
and it's full of grenades and ammunition
the women were
up and resupplying all these guys the
kyuh kyuh was were still supporting you
back to the book inside the villages the
army pilots ran astonishing risks to
find my team aquatic iowa would swoop
down toward the compound flare back at
rooftop level and putter down the
alleyways at 20 miles an hour allowing
the pilots to peer into every backyard
and into every window as the day grew
hotter we gradually cleared the valley
of casualties over 30 wounded or dead
were evacuated we watched a Solano the
lead pilot brought his Chi went down to
a few feet above a trench and hovered
there highlander we spotted five bodies
i'd heard all i needed i jumped out the
door and sprinted across the field to
the right opening some distance but
before Swensen yelled at me I ignored
him knowing he'd be right behind me
a PKM shifted me shifted to me when I
was halfway across the terrace I hopped
over a terrace wall and fell into a deep
well-constructed trench I landed next to
Gunny Johnson and my heart stopped he
was lying on his back with his arms
outspread
his eyes open but never to see anything
again on this earth a few feet further
on I came across the body of a half
grand interpreter who had traveled with
our team I felt sick to my stomach I
knew what I would see next
lieutenant Johnson lay on his back with
his eyes closed
he looked peaceful despite the entry
wounds in his right shoulder da Clayton
lay on top of them with medical supplies
scattered around I rolled him over
doc had taken a three-round burst in the
right cheek off to the right staff
sergeant kenefick was lying face-down
his GPS with a busted screen clenched in
his left hand his mouth was open and
full of dirt I think he was yelling out
his grid location the numbers I heard
over the radio four hours earlier when
he was shot in the back of his head the
team was wiped out their bodies were
stiff and cold most of their gear was
gone weapons helmets radios the 240
machine gun was missing but lieutenant
Johnson's pack was filled with linked
ammo no one had fired the gun I was
supposed to be carrying
I had never believed it would end like
this my mind refused to accept what I
was seeing
hour after hour I had imagined them
holed up inside a stone house shielded
from RPG blasts exchanging gunfire with
the douche men who were who knew better
than to rush them Swanson was standing
above the trench we were taking random
incoming and he was watching for
movement among the houses he talked into
his radio for a few seconds then bent
down and picked up some of the team's
gear he didn't say a word he left me
alone with them I hosted the staff
sergeant over my rolled right shoulder
he was heavy and I fell once he landed
on top of me I got up and carried him to
an Afghan truck carefully tucking him
into the open bed I stood there for a
minute
suddenly beat as I turned away from the
truck half fez put his hand on my
shoulder
the a scars say you carried out they're
dead now they want to help you five or
six of us returned to the trench while
the damned PKM kept shooting at us
I carried Donnie Johnson back the ass
cars took lieutenant Johnson and DA
Clayton Swenson loved back the rest of
the equipment after six hours it was
over then I felt empty as a balloon
without air hafez took me aside they've
gone to a better place he said don't cry
the ass cars will take it as weakness no
way I was going to cry but at that
moment I didn't feel like killing them
with anyone either that wasn't angry or
bitter just deflated and exhausted as
though I had run a marathon and couldn't
remember why I wanted to do it I was too
damn tired to stand still taking fire we
left the valley in a convoy of about
four trucks rods stopped near the
casualty collection point where we
talked with captain Kaplan and captain
and corporal Norman who had walked down
from there observation posts Staff
Sergeant Valdez and Miller radio that
they were coming down from their perch
to everyone
accounted for we had shuttled in and out
of the valley five six or seven times
that morning depending on which one of
us you asked it was all a fog no senior
American officer or pursuit force had
come forward from Camp choice captain
Swenson said he would try to wrap things
up half as and I climbed into the back
of an Afghan truck carrying my dead
brothers I held Staff Sergeant Kent
effect with my left hand and lieutenant
Johnson rested on my right arm as we
bounced down the track we passed
villagers returning to ganja golf some
started to laugh pointing out my dad
friends I reached for my rifle
don't FS said holding my arm not worth
it when we arrived back at camp Joyce I
walked into the battalion aid station to
get body bags Maj Williams rushed up and
clutched at my body armor tell me
they're not all dead not all of them
they're all dead I said removing his
hand I walked outside where my friend
Sergeant Charles Bachus was waiting
Lucas said I'll give you a hand we
walked back to the bodies sergeant major
Jimmy Carr bellow the top enlisted men a
Joyce hastened up and put his hands
firmly on my shoulders trying to steer
me away you don't have to do this devil
dog my guys will make sure it's done
right that wasn't how to end it if I had
died I'd want lieutenant Johnson and
Staff Sergeant Kent effect to put me in
the back I'll finish it I said focus and
I carried the bodies back next to the
freezers take off their battle gear and
dig through their pockets marking items
for shipment to their families I take a
chevron from Staff Sergeant kenefick and
attach it to my
dog tags funny we had started out not
liking each other a thousand years ago
we clean them up as best we can
wiping the blood and dirt off their
faces taking off their field gear
straightening out their camouflage
uniforms and placing each in a black
body bag we marked the name at the head
drape an American flag over each bag bow
our heads in prayer and drive them out
to the helo pad Ganjgal was one of the
deadliest small arms battles of the
Afghanistan war we lost five advisors in
addition to team Monty Army sergeant
first class Westbrook had died of his
wounds
eight a scars were killed in 13
seriously wounded by rifle machine gun
and RPG fire the enemy losses to small
arms were probably of a similar number
there were no IDs no bombs and very few
artillery shells bullets caused most of
the casualties ganja gall was a mountain
fight from an earlier century
and
it's a fight from an earlier century but
uh
but some things don't change it's a fact
yeah it was a Josh you know I say it and
I don't think people understand it but
you know I might not physically died
that day but I died right there next to
him I mean you talk about you know I
mean it's one thing to lose one person
but everybody I mean it's I mean I mean
that's the worst-case scenario you're
living it you know I mean you're
literally you don't even have anybody
from your own team to put your dead on
the bird you know and you know how old
do you at this point 21 the only one
years old
21 21 you know and I I don't know if it
talks about in the book you know after I
did that with my teammates I went
straight from there and I went to so are
the Afghan side and I did it with all
their guys too and usually what they do
with their guys is they just call the
families and they got so many days to
come get him and I wasn't allowing that
I went back and I took body bags up
there and we gave him the exact same
respect that we gave my guys and we put
him in the freezers until their families
came and got him and you know I didn't
go I didn't go start worrying about my
stuff until we'd taken care of all the
all the guys you know and it just is
his long day here's a long day and I
mean you didn't you you're just like
okay you still have a job to do yeah I
so I don't know if it talks about it in
there but that you know they tried to
put me on the helicopter with them to go
back to Bagram and then wanted me to fly
home to do the ramp ceremonies and
wanted me to fly home with them and I
actually put him on there and I told him
I would be right back and I knew those
birds had to take off saying where it's
the PJs weren't gonna sit on the flight
line very long and I just made sure that
I knew that they took off before I got
around anybody else because I mean they
were dead I mean I still had guys that
still needed me and they didn't need me
anymore mm-hmm and so I you know I just
you know I knew my Afghan soldiers
needed me they need to see that that
they weren't alone they needed to see
that that we're in this together
you know and that was what that was what
mattered to me but what the guys I still
had left how did the Afghan your Afghan
soldiers respond to this whole situation
you know sometimes in Iraq there'd be a
mass casualty like this and we'd lose a
whole there was actually in Ramadi we
lost a whole battalion they all they all
left
yeah they quit yeah what were your guys
did how did it affect him I mean they
stuck it out you know they stuck it out
they did I mean I'm telling you they
they're some of the most incredible
human beings ever seen you know we come
in and deploy we're there for a certain
amount of time they live it forever and
they responded I mean they you know they
got their [ __ ] together and
I mean we were back in the fight three
days later you know and they don't get
they don't get to respond get to support
we do you know they don't get I mean
they don't get anything we get you know
what I mean and and it's just you know
but we but we stuck together you know
they help me they help me get through it
and I hope I help them but I think the
most incredible thing was it was at that
point that that they brought me into
there I was accepted as one of them you
were one of them and that was probably
the most rewarding piece of it to me you
know was that I I had finally proven
myself to them that that I was one of
them in deployment wasn't over yet
and you know there was more fighting to
be done going back to the book army an
army convoy had been ambushed north of
Monte Lieutenant current captain Bryant
the company commander were on their way
to assist I looked at colonel you who
nodded in agreement minutes later you
Bachus staff sergeant Richards and some
of the Colonel's guys that came with him
a dozen a scars and I were headed out
the gate and basically what you run into
is there's a huge kind of what did
somebody hit an ie D is that what had
happened it wasn't all day ambush beside
this and they what they done that they
blew the jingo trucks up and blocked the
road so that you know they intertwined
those jingo trucks in between the u.s.
convoy and it's so stupid and so the
jingo truck is blown up and it's
blocking the road so guess what happens
the rest of them they're all certain and
you can't go around it because it's
about a 250 foot drop off into the Kunar
river on the side so they're stuck on
the side of this and I've been listening
to it on the radio for a long time and I
knew they were gonna get slaughtered I
knew that you weren't just gonna sit
there and they had buttoned up mmm so
that's what you were talking about
earlier you button up and you wait well
now they're gonna maneuver
yep and that's what they were and that's
what they were doing so the guys and the
jingo trucks had jumped out and I kept I
kept asking over the radio you know I
cuz I could monitor and I kept asking
over the raid and I could see the smoke
from where I was headed and I kept
asking over the radio as a clip platoon
and I kept combat logistics platoon and
I kept asking over the radio how many
rounds have you fired because I was
afraid they were gonna get low on ammo
zero damn so that's when you rolled out
you get out there and this is three days
after Gangi go damn pkms and aks were
hammering down on this mess with little
returned fire would be crazy to drive
into that tangle of vehicles is it focus
or bacchus focus yeah focus focus was on
the mark-19 on our truck he couldn't
shoot because the angles of fire Richard
stayed in the driver's seat why advanced
on foot by bounds into the wreckage our
ass cars were on ran forward with us but
their light m16s didn't impress the
Taliban machine gun crew I was quickly
pinned behind a disabled truck looking
up I could see the PKM was shooting from
a thick stone house 200 meters upslope I
accident argit's excited to have his
target so close I fired about five
shells from my grenade launcher before
my common sense kicked in what am i
doing I thought I'm out bad out matched
by a machine gun but he there's an army
Humvee sitting next to me with no one in
the 50 Cal turret you run over there man
you're 50 Cal I yelled we're logistics
came to muffled reply we don't fight
some supply guys can't wait to get into
the action but not this gang I wasn't
worried though Wildman Kerr would soon
have air on station bodies were
scattered all over the road all
civilians lying face down next to me
alongside the army truck was a skinny
teenager and a t-shirt bleeding from
shrapnel in his chest and his left arm
he was a pathetic sight sprawled on his
back in his filthy brown shorts an
orange tip needle protruding from above
his heart and a plastic stopper shoved
above his left nostril
he didn't weigh as much as I ate in a
day his hands and feet were uglier than
the dirt from his efforts to crawl out
of the line of fire he wasn't old enough
to grow a beard but he had a full shock
of black hair not a bad-looking
kid once he was cleaned up at the aid
station and had some ice cream he'd be
okay I felt good in fact I was pumped
I had applied dozens of tourniquets but
this is the first time I had smelled
death hiss out and that's because he
needled him down and I didn't cover that
part he has a sucking chest wound and
you you gave him a decompression I had
saved a human being a poor scrawny kid
eking out a living by driving a banged
up truck past known ambush sites would
he even would he eventually joined the
Taliban and betray an American convoy I
had no idea sure some of the villagers
had gone to Gaul had been real pricks
but why should I hold it against this
kid I ran back down the road
hoisting up another wounded truck driver
and carried him back then I stopped to
check on the skinny kid I wanted to pat
him on the shoulder to make myself feel
good for my supposedly wonderful deed
only he was dead
he had bled to death from the wound to
his left arm the crew in the army truck
had let him bleed out not five feet away
because he was an Afghan and they were
afraid damn it the Afghan drivers were
all hunted together in a ditch by the
river
the ambush had been sprung about 90
minutes earlier by now they had pissed
themselves dry and had nowhere to go I
banged my rifle on I don't bang my rifle
but on an army truck yelling to the
soldiers to open up at least give me
some water for those poor bastards I
shouted a sheepish medic got out of the
truck with several bottles of water and
his med pack and ran over the ditch I
knelt there looking at the blood-stained
stains from the kid right beside the
truck door I banged on the steel door
again it opened a crack [ __ ] you I said
to the captain inside
[Music]
as the traffic jam was sorted out
colonel you and I walked back to our
Humvee the dead key kid lay on the hood
and rather than ride to base with a
corpse between us we wedged the body in
the trunk sometimes you laugh sometimes
you want to cry before dropping a shell
down a mortar tube the gunner levels the
bubbles on his sight if he loses the
bubbles then the tube is pointed at a
crazy angle after ganja gall I was
losing the bubble so investigations take
place there's actually a guy you know
accusations and excuses and one of the
terms that that was in there that was
that there was it was being said that
there was poor battle management yeah
and you're talking to a psychologist on
site at this time and you know that's
some of the support you were talking
about that we might have that an Afghan
kid in the Afghan army might not have
and it was a feat was it a female yeah
captain Katie cop and she was making
some assessments back to the book it's
true I didn't feel connected with others
the ass cars were smoking hash jabbering
on their cell phones and wandering
around in flip-flops the American
soldiers were playing video games
stuffing themselves at dinner laughing
too loudly at nothing we weren't
fighting a war we were holding a few
acres of dirt while the war swirled all
around outside our barbed wire there
were dushman in every Valley drink tea
with the villagers pay $40 for a chicken
we were in Kumar to fight let's get it
on that was my attitude the psychologist
insisted that I go back to the States
for treatment no thanks as a captain she
had the rank to make a recommendation
stick but she wanted my agreement so she
challenged me we would play a game of
ping pong if I won I could stay I lost
by one point she was very good and she
really was worried about me and cared
about me I knew that it was my time to
go home
a ping-pong game was she like a legit
ping-pong player no I thought I had her
you know I was the only you know it was
either you know I it was probably best I
went home I would say if it wasn't if I
didn't go home I I would have never came
home
you know I was just getting well and
tighter and tighter I mean I was you
couldn't tell me you couldn't tell me I
was not I wasn't I wasn't command like
you couldn't you couldn't tell me what
to do you were out of control
I was I was not a control yeah I mean
you know I wasn't doing anything any
nothing you know it morally unethical
right like nothing I was doing my job
but as far as like commanding me you
couldn't you you were gonna do what you
were gonna do yeah absolutely I mean I
was you know I was at the point to where
I had no I had no I didn't trust my
command I didn't trust anybody I didn't
trust anybody was gonna mean it was I
was one you know not a one man I was a
three-man operation right I mean I was
but I was a one-man I was a one-man
wrecking crew right like I was I mean I
was gonna do yeah you weren't gonna tell
me anything I mean there was it was
pretty bad I mean I was fighting now you
know the fist fighting you know how much
more how much longer was it that you
actually lost the ping-pong match and
got sent home I lost it right a couple
days before Thanksgiving okay so I was
like you were there for another what's
Thanksgiving though and yes and we
fought our ass off the whole time the
whole time it was it was we fought
her ass is off almost every single day
and sometimes three and four times a day
well that momentum that you talked about
in the valley they built it it keeps
coming right it keeps coming because
right after that they overrun Keating
right after I mean it's all that all of
it you know they just built so much
momentum and they
were hammering us I mean we're hammering
us every day and you know it was it was
pretty bad so you get sent home here we
go back to the book when I got home in
December I felt like I landed on the
moon everyone around me was excited
about football Christmas and other
normal things I was looking at the
clapboard houses and the cars thinking
man that's so flimsy they wouldn't give
cover worth [ __ ] in the firefight it was
an exposed feeling and where were my
machine guns I found my old pistol and
kept it around like a rabbit's foot but
I missed my two 40s and my 50 cals
something awful it seems weird I'm sure
but I really just wasn't buying that
there wasn't some enemy about to come
over the green hills and I felt so
unprepared I wouldn't be any good to
protect anybody I was soon sent off to
Fort Thomas Kentucky for PTSD therapy
maybe that would settle me down let me
get some sleep and stop feeling so
depressed and angry at every little
thing some guys really go nuts when they
come back and I wasn't in danger of that
but I could feel the kind of crazy
things that maybe got the better of them
you're over there long enough and under
such constant battle stress that it
resets all your settings the way way
into the red and they're very hard to
set back the main thing knowing was that
I didn't get my friends out as I had
promised I'd spent a good part of my 21
years being pretty caracal of other
people who failed at their
responsibilities and now it was all
coming back on me in a big dump truck
every day the psychologist urged us to
step back and identify why we were
experiencing negative emotions in other
words take a minute to really be
conscious of the emotion instead of just
letting it seep in don't let your mind
stay in neutral watch your thoughts and
by the way I'm hitting this stuff pretty
hard because a lot of people that listen
to this podcast are thinking these
things right here but I think that's an
important part don't let your mind stay
in neutral watch your thoughts refusing
to get out of bed or go to work or smile
at others are all decisions find the
reasons those decisions and turn
negative feelings into positive actions
it's not enough to identify why you're
feeling bad it's about having the
character to do something positive to
take up that space don't wallow in your
misery which is just selfish childish
self absorption it was all good stuff
all I ever need is a good operating
manual so you're getting some good
instructions yeah not with you no I
can't say that the the PTSD Center
helped me but what it did is it educated
me it educated me on why I was feeling
the way I was and what it was and then
therefore that helped me deal with it
right it kind of like you know you know
you know you know kind of like how you
know your diet that works for you you
know like you can look in the mirror you
how you feel after you eat it right
though it's kind of the same thing like
it educates you on why your body is
doing this or why you're having this
reaction you know and and that it's
normal and it's just you know and this
is why it's doing it and this is how you
help counter it right and that was kind
of that was kind of what it did for me
it didn't I don't think it really it
didn't it didn't fix anything it just
educated me on what the problem was so
you could start to identify the problem
yes so I could identify the problem I
could identify why I was feeling this
way and then you know I could make
decisions based of how I could was that
when you look at the root of that
problem
was it that feeling of like hey the
promise that you made was I'll get you
guys out no I mean no I mean the facts
of the facts are like here's I get so
frustrated with people who want it like
like I'm a factual guy like you know I
mean I I'm everything to me is black and
white and I'm a back face like I I went
in that day to go get my teammates out I
failed I failed there's no you can't
jump around you can't you can't ignore
the facts of what happened I failed I
failed miserably and so you know you if
you tell you if I tell myself I didn't
fell I'll I'm lying to myself so for me
you know I failed I was tested and I
failed and now I have to figure out what
to do with that and that's part of it
you know and that and that's why I get
so upset about like you know the
counselors or whatever right no well you
didn't fail no no no like as soon as
they say that to me yeah I'm done I'm
done cuz no that's I'm not gonna lie to
myself I failed and now I need to deal
with it I need to deal with it you know
I can't lie and that's and I mean look I
mean it's it mmm
I always say the equivalent to try to
make people understand like how to how I
feel about it and the situation is it
would be like you inside of a house and
your family's there and the house
catches on fire and you end up getting
out thinking that maybe they're all out
and you can't get back in there and they
all burn to death that's kind of the
equivalent of it and you know so I just
have to deal with it and and you know I
deal with it the best I can every day I
learn from it I try to turn it into
something good but at the end of the day
I still failed and
you know that's that's the way it goes
going back to the book man after my two
months at the clinic Mike my enlistment
term was in fact coming to an end it
didn't take a genius to see it I'd be B
end I'd end up behind a desk so I chose
not to re-enlist
I love the core so it hurt before
joining the core I had three concussions
mononucleosis and an operation on my
right knee when I mustered out four
years later I'd added to operations on
my right hand a right road rotator cuff
operation a fourth concussion from an
RPG a dislocated shoulder and two
herniated discs from clumsily lifting
the dead and wounded one vertebrae given
Wayne Gonzaga when I picked up a NASCAR
and slipped in the bloody mud under him
I have no idea when the second vertebrae
went out during the battle I had that
nick in my arm from a bullet or shrapnel
but that hadn't been anything I was in
deep a decent shape for construction
work I figured after the PTSD clinic I
returned to Kentucky it was the winter
of 2010 and I warm myself up by slipping
back into hard-drinking each night I
hadn't seen an active-duty grunt in
months Fabio and Rodriguez Chavez were
due to receive the Navy Navy crosses at
the Marine Corps Base in Quantico but I
couldn't get enough time off to fly back
east where you work in construction at
this point and your boys are getting
Navy crosses you can't get time off from
work Swanson and I had been recommended
for the Medal of Honor we knew that no
we knew though that the award was
usually downgraded upon review when I
drank which was too much I'd laugh at
the absurdity I'd screwed up big time my
achievement
was losing my brothers the Marine Corps
would come to its senses and I'd never
hear another word from another devil dog
I had no idea what was in front of me
and I didn't care I couldn't take a walk
turn on the TV or read a book to
distract my mind the emptiness of my
life was the dark all around me with
nothing to see in any direction four
years ago I'd left the farm for an
adventure in a new beginning the cord
shaped me and I had arrived in
Afghanistan confident I do well in
combat sure enough up at Monte I had
emerged as the young gun everyday
brought fun danger against the backdrop
of spectacular mountains it was fun
stuff shooting thousands of rounds not
losing many people and seeing the damage
you inflicted there was no weapon I
couldn't handle and my team trusted me
to get them out of any hot spot my
cockiness put us in but when it counted
most I wasn't with them they weren't
trained to do my job
Gunny Johnson didn't spend every day
behind a 240 stash Staff Sergeant
kenefick wasn't comfortable with weapons
her ankles a fire doc Layton wasn't a
fighter and lieutenant Johnson didn't
adjust fire missions we aren't worried
we know you'll get us out if anything
goes bad Meyer well I didn't lieutenant
that was a load of worthless [ __ ] not
there when you needed me around 3:00 in
the morning
I pulled my truck into the driveway of a
shop owned by my high school friend
Derek Yates and cut the engine I turned
on the cab light and fished out my cell
phone it wasn't right to burn my dad but
I wanted to connect one last time with
someone I packed out a text message to
my friends and in tobe they had known me
since I was a toddler but they didn't
know me that well did they hear I was
back
where I had started with an aluminum
bracelet with two names on each wrist
that's what I had done with my life lost
four brothers I can't do it anymore I
typed I reached into the glove
compartment where I kept my Glock if I
always kept a full magazine with a round
chambered in the pistol a Glock doesn't
have a safety you pulled the trigger and
the weapon fires I stuck the gun to my
head then squeeze the trigger click
nothing nada no round in the chamber as
you can imagine i sat there quite
sobered up and in double shock suicide
is terminal self revulsion I was mixed
up but I knew my team would be
disappointed in me
Staff Sergeant Ken effect would give me
hell which is where I would be bad
ending that was not going to happen
but who downloaded my pistol right on
the spot I knew who had done it
have I ever talked to that person about
it no I put away the pistol and drove
home that night I experienced no sudden
change of direction in my life
I didn't know where I was headed in the
future but I knew I knew quitting wasn't
right not that night not ever
you know I had never told I had never
told anybody about that night until it
was published in a book and I just you
know I just felt like it was important
to the story because I didn't want
people to read the story and then just
think that it was all okay when I came
home I didn't want to give them that
perspective and there's so many guys out
there that write these books of the
crazy [ __ ] that they do but they never
talk about what what that crazy [ __ ]
does to them
yeah they never talked about that and so
what happens is is people read that and
they're like holy [ __ ] that's that's
crazy
I could never do that because I deal
with problems and it's like yeah we all
do and you know I had to put it in to I
wanted people to know that I'm just a
human I'm no different than them and I
felt like that I couldn't put in the if
you want to call it good stuff and not
put in the bad stuff it's
I'm sure there's some psychologists that
could figure something out about this
but you got to the point right and you
made the decision clearly and you came
out the other side by the grace of God
and who ever knew you well enough to
figure out that they needed to make sure
you didn't have a loaded gun but that's
a message for anybody that feels like
they're in the same situation you felt
like you were in which is that there's
not not going to get any better is like
okay come out the other side man come
out the other side and it was like I
mean like you said it's not a sudden
change in direction but you but you knew
no I couldn't quit I always like to say
that you know sometimes you find
yourself in the middle of nowhere and
sometimes in the middle of nowhere you
find yourself and you know I I'm I had
no idea what my life is going I made a
deal with myself you know I had set
there and I had said if I'm gonna keep
living this life this way rock rock it
back and get over with but I said if I
ever put the car and drive I'll never
look back and I sit there I'm not gonna
lie to you I probably sit there for 5-10
minutes and I done it it at my buddy's
shot because I knew he'd be there at 8
o'clock in the morning and he could just
find me and I put in Drive and I just I
never looked back you know I you know
and it's I'm lucky I'm fortunate that
the gun didn't go off right but you know
I think that you know you always got to
hit that rock bottom you know they think
that and that was for me that was it
that was the rock bottom and it you know
it changed it and I mean again I just
want to stress this as much as I can too
cuz
me I hear from people especially from
veterans that are that are walking this
line man and they're walking this line
and if you're walking that line hold it
listen it's not worth it I mean it's not
like you know I had to change honestly I
had to change the way that I looked at
life
the only problem there was is me you
know instead of just facing it and
saying hey look I want to fix this
problem I was blaming everybody else for
my problems and what I had to do was I
had to say you know okay if you know if
the things that I seen were so bad I've
seen what freedom cost firsthand that's
what's got me there so if anything I
have more reason than anybody else in
the face this planet to go out and make
the most of my life because I've seen it
firsthand of what it costs so instead of
walking around it feels like you know
I'm not feeling sorry for my teammates
because they're in a better place they
don't feel anymore I'm really just
feeling sorry for myself
and then by doing that I'm sack I'm
wasting the sacrifices that they made on
my behalf
and I had to change the way I looked at
it instead of using it as my excuse I
had to use it as my fuel and that's a
choice that is a conscious choice you
wake up every day and you decide how you
look at the situation you decide what
you do with that you decide whether you
use it as your excuse to hold you back
or you use it as your easy a you know
valve of of hiding who you are or you
use it as your fuel to go out and be the
best that you can be you decide that
nobody does nobody else does you do
every day and it is a conscious choice I
mean I still deal with it but I still
make the choice
that's awesome that's awesome anybody
that's listening like I said anybody
that's listening and that's that's
walking that line there you go make the
right choice make the right choice make
the choice make the right choice and you
know what the right choice is yeah I
mean you're talking about how much and
and and I feel this to like every day
how much am i letting down my friends
that didn't come home if I'm not doing
everything I can to take advantage of
the gift they gave me if to be sitting
here right now
right I mean I mean I any day that I
don't want to go on and push on for
myself I can look down I'll bet you
anything I got four reasons right here
that would switch me one day they would
switch me my worst day to have one more
day you know and and and I just you know
I'm not okay with letting their
sacrifices be wasted I'm not okay with
watching anybody else waste them so why
would I be okay with what letting myself
waste them
well
another thing I want to say is like
walking that line I want to say this and
get it out there it's normal it's normal
it doesn't mean you're weak it doesn't I
want to get that that stigma out there
you know I want to get that off the
books is it's it is a normal like I
don't understand why why it's okay in
our society or in the military a guy
breaks his leg okay do you go get make
him run tomorrow he puts a cast on it
he rehabs it it's the same thing with
the mind it's the same thing it's the
same thing you go in and you watch the
people you have to worry about are the
ones that go watch their close friends
and they watch human beings and they
watch this evil and people die and
suffer and don't have a reaction those
are the ones you have to worry about it
is a normal reaction to a not normal
situation and it's okay it's okay
it is 110 percent okay
absolutely man absolutely as you we
mentioned quickly you know there was
some buzz possibly about about you
getting marijuana yeah and but you know
how it goes like it was all I didn't
believe it I never I never had any idea
you know you hear talk about it Silver
Star Medal of Honor Navy Cross whatever
right I didn't care I didn't I
I promised the last thing that I ever
thought about was an award an award
that's the last thing well it gets
approved
and going back to the book when the
president hung that medal around my neck
I felt glum I couldn't smile and I said
nothing
I gave no remarks and avoided the press
as a Marine you either bring your team
home alive or you die trying my country
was recognizing me for being a failure
and for the worst day of my life the
marine commandant General Jim Amos and
general Joe Joseph Dunford attended the
ceremony
throughout the years after ganja golf
the Marine Corps leadership has provided
consistent support not just to me but to
all who fought there the top enlisted
man in the Marine Corps sergeant major
Mike Barrett twice came to our farm to
meet my dad and granddad and to
encourage me there's no such thing as a
former Marine fifty years after they
have left active duty marine still sign
emails to each other with SF Semper
Fidelis always faithful of course we
have among us those who fail themselves
their family in society the fact remains
though that the Corps expects every
marine to live by a set of core values
in turn the Corps keeps its side of the
bargain
you cannot ask anything more of an
organization than that the Medal of
Honor given in the name of the Congress
of the United States of America
symbolizes the courage and determination
of our entire country and speaking of
the country you were in New York I was
in New York City at the twin towers site
Ground Zero with Gunny Joshua Peterson
someone I knew from my first days in the
Corps we were greeted by hundreds of
police firemen construction workers Wall
Street guys in suits city officials and
the families of the Fallen
meir I can't believe this scene Donnie
Peterson said make sure your ribbons are
squared away
we stood side-by-side - grunts and
sharply ironed khakis waving like we had
won an election I thought of my sad
fumbling meetings with the family of
team Monti the families of team Monti
when I couldn't think of much to say I
was alive and their loved ones were not
now here I was standing before a
monument for 3,000 dead I saw some big
iron workers and hard hats standing off
to one side when the ceremony ended they
sneaked me in onto a work elevator up we
went to the top of the ride where we
then climbed wooden ladders until we
couldn't go any further and there
weren't any guardrails I stood there
looking out at the most beautiful
country in the world trying to make
sense of my feelings this was where it
had all started so many good people lost
the people had been working here and the
people I had known who had not gone
blindly into uniform they had reasoned
why Americans do that but they had gone
ahead to do and to die an ironworker
handed me a silver marker then I wrote
on a girder for those who gave all
for those who gave all and that wraps up
the book and
you know you're talking about awards and
what you hear and what happens and all
that and then I wanted to say this as
well on the battlefield on that
battlefield and on every battle there
are acts of extreme valor that no one
will ever know about I'm talking about
an infinite number no one's ever gonna
know about them
and it's important to know this that our
military men and women don't do what
they do for medals or ribbons they do
what they do because they love freedom
because they love America because they
love their comrades in arms and that
right there is why our country thrives
in battle not because of technological
advances not because of superior
weaponry not even the size of our
military it's because of the bond that
is shared between warriors that is a
real strength then Dakota that's
something that you represent in spades
then they don't want to thank you for
coming on the podcast and sharing this
incredible story and I know it's not
only a story of you but it's a story of
all the men American and Afghan as well
that rode into battle with you that day
and showed once again what it is that
makes America a place of of hope and of
freedom it's because of it's because of
men it's because of individual men that
in their heart and even in the face of
death actually live actually live the
ideals of this great nation not only in
their words but in their actions in the
way that they live and in the way that
they died
got boys all incredible you know I mean
you're exactly right like I mean there's
so many stories that are I mean people
have done so many stories of people
doing such incredible stuff and you know
it's it's it's literally out of the love
of another human being
it's literally I the love of making the
world a better place that's really
that's really all we do it's all we do
I mean we join nobody joins it okay
to go just shoot people or fight they
literally join to to try to make the
world around them a better place whether
it's passing out a whether it's
rendering aid to a civilian or to you
know a fellow American or whether it's
taken out the bully that's inflicting
fear in that place every thing that we
do is to try to make the world just a
little bit better that's it you know as
I was reading about when you got back to
your team you could see I mean just from
the way that guys were laid out you know
staff sergeant was trying to get coms
and trying to pass grids and doc was
working on the boss I mean everyone was
trying to make things happen
and who knows what those moments were
like you know but there's moments if
there's there's heroism there that we're
never gonna know about no I mean I mean
a hundred percent I mean doc Layton was
rendering aid you know what stopped him
was because Fazio was with him what
stopped him of getting to the road was
lieutenant Johnson got hit and Gunny
kenefick and Gunny Johnson were on
either side providing security while da
Clayton worked on him and that was the
medevac we heard call
from Gunny kenefick was trying to call
that medivac in for lieutenant Johnson
prayer and you know but they weren't
gonna they weren't gonna leave him
behind even more even more of not
leaving him behind
they weren't gonna just throw him over
his shoulder and get him out they were
gonna try to fix him I mean what do you
say well what do you say I mean you know
that right there I mean that right
there's everything I mean you take that
you take I mean there's so many actions
I mean I've watched people do such
incredible things such incredible things
that just make what I do I mean no you
know no makes me look like I you know
I've done nothing I haven't seen it you
know people are incredible well again
man I can't thank you enough for coming
on now thank you on on the podcast and
hanging out and being out there and
kicking ass and talking smack to people
I like that too yeah I miss anything
anything else no no I mean yeah thank
you thank you cover it all yeah I think
you covered it you know echo yes you got
any questions for the man over there no
usually I come up with some
light-hearted question but man I'm out
of words to be honest we took that
little break yeah and that goes like man
is that guy just keeps the sec I'm
sitting there thinking to myself this
really happened man and I'm like yeah I
told I gave I give echo heads-up
sometimes you know I say hey man it's
gonna be heavy one or whatever and I was
like told him this afternoon I'm like
Amen it's gonna be a heavy one you know
stand by and you know we're downstairs
when we were taking that break he's like
man
oh all this really happened I said yeah
and you know who it happened to the guy
we're sitting in a room with and his
friends like that's what happened so uh
you know I early on when I started this
podcast I'd be reading a book from night
from World War one yeah or I'd be
reading the book from World War two or
Vietnam or whatever and I died like
after but I don't know how many podcasts
but like seven or eight podcasts I was
like hey I just want to stop for a
second and remind everybody that the the
characters that I'm talking about in
these books these characters they're not
characters in a movie there they're
people they're they're humans and this
stuff that we're talking about really
happened to these people so again it's
obviously haven't you sitting here and I
was talking to you about when when
Colonel William reader was in here and
you know you're like you're reading
stuff that happened to him he was
tortured he was mock executions he had
he had he was locked in a bamboo
two-foot tall bamboo cage in the jungles
in Vietnam and he's got his legs and
shackles and the he's trying to sleep
and he's getting woken up by the rats
that are eating the wounds and his legs
and it's like that that's just
inconceivable I mean it had happened
yeah I mean that's you know I hear
stories like that and just you know
that's real people these are real people
just like us yeah in in in honestly man
I mean I'm sure you saw me like
sometimes you know I'm yeah I'm getting
I get emotional when I read your story
but why do I get emotional when I read
your stories because I'm thinking of
everything I've been thinking about my
friends and I'm just like it's man you
know it's uh it's real and and for those
of you people that are listening to this
and I talked to I dressed like the
veterans out there a bunch today but you
know to those of you that
didn't have the opportunity to serve for
whatever reason you know if I could
relate something to you it's like yeah
these these people these lieutenants
these sergeants these staff sergeants
and they're people man
they're people yeah they're just they're
just people
yep they're just people I mean that's
they're just people they're just and and
you know and I think that that's kind of
what makes it hard for Society of is
that they see so many of these movies
and they read these books and you know
they read it but what they don't
understand is that somebody lived it you
know and I think that that's a
perspective that you always have to
remind yourself of is that yeah you're
reading it and but somebody lived it you
know yeah then you kind of see you know
on the news like oh yeah the Medal of
Honor ceremony and the pictures you know
of you honey
and you know you see the president
putting it on wow that's so great or
whatever and what you don't
what we don't see you know people who
haven't served is like what really
happened to talk to arrived at that one
quote-unquote glorious moment Matt oh my
gosh thank you let's go party or so I
don't know something you know like it
says yes a Danko did yeah people think
it's just so great you know and I got I
despised everything that metal stands
for for me you know me not anybody else
but I you know when I put that medal
around my neck to me it's literally
here's the stamp to show the world how
bad I failed here's the you know that's
why I don't I don't wear it I don't I
don't wear it because you know it's the
worst day of my life
and I lost everything that day I lost
not just my team I lost my career in the
Marine Corps I mean everything that I
wanted to be was gone within one day and
you know and then I get recognized for
it
you know so not only do you have to live
with it but now you have to live with it
in the face of the nation
well from that perspective from from my
perspective looking at that for one
thing the medal
yeah I mean it was put around your neck
but I believe that medal represents
everyone that was with your team yeah
and you might have gotten the the metal
put around your neck but it's it
represents that story's gonna be told
over and over again and your name might
be at the top of the list but every name
is gonna be on that list everyone's
gonna know and I mean obviously I can't
imagine the burden that comes with that
metal that you live with but at the same
time being able to have that you have
your brothers remembered I think that it
makes it worthwhile and and you know in
that and that's the piece of it you're
right I mean so on the selfish you know
when I what I just said was on the
selfish side of it right that that that
is for me that that is the only reason I
did accept the medal was because I want
my teammates to live on forever I want
people to know who they were because the
day that I stop speaking their name is
the day they truly die and I have an
obligation that as long as I can still
breathe that their names are still need
to be told and so that's what that metal
allows me to do and it is their metal I
mean it's it's for them but yeah I mean
you know you don't it's just it goes
against you know and I think the one
thing
you know that is so hard for us to wrap
around is how many times in your
training did you how many times did you
sit like when you were training guys and
this and that how many times did you
ever set them up for when they did
everything that they could they failed
hate to be honest with you when I was
running training I did that all the time
yeah I'm not kidding I mean you can talk
to anybody that went through training
when I ran it it was it was just mayhem
and it was you were gonna you know you
were gonna carry out bodies you you had
16 guys in a platoon you were gonna be
carrying six bodies yeah out and you're
gonna be carrying them for four
kilometers to a helicopter extract which
wasn't gonna show up and you're gonna
have to go another six it would it was
brutal
yeah and there was times there was times
where I'd kill every single you know
training I'd kill every single seal
because they were not doing what they
were supposed to do and they were making
mistakes so the leadership wasn't
stepping up I did that all the time yeah
I did it all the time I mean I can't I I
came back from Ramadi where my guys were
some really bad situations and I wanted
everyone to be ready for that man and
like that was it was I mean I was not I
mean I I came back from deployment got
put in charge of training it was awesome
it was the best thing that I ever could
have done for me and and I I thought it
was the best thing I could do for my
teammates was to be like okay we're
gonna make this training hard really
hard and and so probably not you
probably thought doesn't say never look
man when I was running training and an
ant Donets that's awesome and I had God
I mean I had many guys that came back
from Iraq and Afghanistan and and would
say like yeah a man we got we got
hammered hard in this situation and we
were ready nothing as bad as your
situation but yeah but the mentality of
it is you know there are some situations
you're not gonna win there are some
situations where you show up and you're
not gonna win and that's against
everything that we believe and
everything that we're taught you
you know I mean that that if we do our
job and we do it right and you still
lose it doesn't make sense well that's
not something I've told many guises man
you you can do everything right you can
make no mistakes and you can still get
killed
you can still loot you can still think
you know there's decisions that you make
on the battlefield you say if you say
okay go left you can go left and
everyone could be great and it's the
best decision evident you could say go
left and everyone could dine it's the
worst decision ever there's there's
things that you can't control inside of
combat so you prepare and train as hard
as you can and and the other thing you
do is you get the leadership in the city
that they're not gonna put themselves
this is like if my guys plan something
that was stupid I'd let a Mexico this is
in training if they did they came up
with a dumb plan they were gonna execute
that plan I wasn't gonna stop them and
they were gonna get slaughtered
so they'd learn some lessons but that's
why that training is so important and
it's important in everything 9 percent 9
percent I appreciate you having me on
yeah thanks for coming on brother I
think some money man is awesome man
Yeah right I do not accept that from you
you are the man
all right echo yes talk about something
good sure chill a little bit get what
you mean
ok shift gears kind of a rough
transition don't let me know that we're
like three hours plus right now so you
could talk quickly if you want if I want
please mm-hmm
see how I kind of recommend well I feel
like me and Dakota that we have some
catching up to do you guys been talking
so you know I might drag this a little
bit no okay
so or you mean this is where you get
Jocko supplements krill oil joint
warfare it's free two joints free joints
this important supplement yes important
supplement yeah also he has one called
discipline for cognitive and physical
enhancement supplement pre-workout
pre-mission so what's called it's a good
one
also at origin may its origin main comm
main the state not like
the mean one yeah yeah and I like it
yeah yeah it's good um you got keys on
there for jujitsu you trained you
jittery I do yeah so if you get the
origin key those are all made in America
everything in origin o me let me get you
an Origin Giessen see our main American
you gotta represent from threads from
the cotton by the way you grow the
continent America not the kind they
import the the fabric and we assemble
them that everything from see what is it
from seeds tips from seat from dirt to
shirt - shirt there - sure - sure I'm
pretty good right yeah it was good I
liked it they got some rash guards on
their spats yeah do that see bats are
yeah yeah you know what's bad sir no
yeah we didn't really either
we had to County we had to research it
arrived it's Beth here's the bottom line
spend expand their spandex their tights
basically I'm a freshman gear
where'd you trip do you train a 10th
planet yeah some some times have you
seen dudes down there as plain planets
all about them oh yeah they're all about
they're all about the spy was worried
about impression I wasn't worried about
using the word spats cuz I didn't
sounded like maybe it was some kind of
like yeah let's just say we sounded kind
of girlish like some girl with like like
a girl would be like oh man works like
I'm not there were Spanx what are those
thanks real tight like like it's it's
kind of it's essentially compression it
is it's compression you're like yeah
like so like I compress yeah yeah okay
to compress they should be they should
be illegal I figured out somebody I
should be illegal because it's like
selling I was on we were on like some
kind of live broadcast and someone with
spats is comes from what soldiers
cavalry soldiers in world war one war
like leggings and they were called spats
and I was like okay it's cool well we'll
say it now yeah I like it
we're relieved in legging they're just
it's like this lower you know that lower
part that covers the boot yeah it's that
yeah wait up that is not spats that's
something else one of those things
called do you ever do honor guard you
had to wear those things no I think they
were actually called leggings wait
so we're unclear about what no I know
what's bad sir I mean I am I'm a very
unclear because in football you tape
your shoe and your ya ankle oh yeah
that's fat so I just you know I like it
hey you know what it's worth it works it
does right yeah nonetheless origin has
some spats some compression gear rash
guard added said it's all made America
good stuff where do you mean calm go on
there check out all their stuff if you
like something get something also for
the kettlebells that I have trained it
on it planet yeah on it you know the
kettlebells primal bells yeah got the
little set yeah he's very proud of that
whatever you seems like yeah you know
primal soldier no oh yeah what's that
primal what swell swell smolder yeah
yeah like he's a big kettlebell guys
[Music]
boom so he'd yeah so anyway on it calm /
taco that's where you get into
kettlebells you want to get the whole
set like me or you know or other stuff
like I said um if you actually I said
this before yeah you want to vary up
your workout make it more interesting
chocolate like sport workouts that's
cool too but if you want to make more
interesting get the Mase get you know
these some more what do you call it like
more creative
yeah the Mase fitness equipment yeah on
a.com slash juncos good spot also when
you buy the book into the fire Dakota
Meyer don't worry I got it listed on our
website podcast calm by episode by the
way along with all the books that we go
over on this podcast boom just click
through there take it Amazon shop
continue doing shopping if you want good
way to support also subscribe to the
podcast if you haven't already stitcher
iTunes Google Play
Spotify I just I just learned what
Spotify wasn't they me - I'm not even on
that today
I know what it is yes good thing but
we're on it yeah that's all Alexa you
have a LexA I've never heard of her okay
go oh well you can ask it to play jockle
podcasts way out no way yeah yeah I'm
gonna buy one just be like Alexa play
Taco podcast and then it says playing
the latest episode of chuckle podcast so
cool and you always say do you have
Alexa that's like saying hey do you have
or you should go buy a Siri you can't
buy Siri Siri comes with no your phone
no no no you can buy Alexa no yes not by
an Alexa by an Amazon no one calls it
that though no one talks about that
maybe they should because that's the
correct thing we don't want to confuse
people no the only one that's you wanna
go to you know you doing economic people
talking about Alexa alright know that
I'm alright if you're gonna dip in on
this believe me I know it's a tube an
intelligent - why does it have to do
about you get that Amazon echo yeah and
then you ask Alexa
so essentially alex is in that basket
what if I wanted to ask echo it won't it
won't respond you can call me out
whenever I'll respond will not respond
to the name Alexa lives in Amazon echo
just like Siri lives in your iPhone
there's nothing living in my iPhone it's
a machine it's it's artificial like girl
a chance nonetheless subscribe if you
haven't already also so Christ subscribe
to YouTube we'll have the video version
of this podcast and excerpts on there as
well an enhanced excerpts as well if
you're into that subscribe YouTube your
friend to youtube also Jaco as a store
Jaakko store mmm just like it's called
jaakko podcast jaco store cuz it's a
store I like it's called Jaco I'm not
back if I had a badass name
Jaakko your name is Dakota come on I
know everybody thinks it's like a girl
though oh really is that girl's name
Dakota
yeah Dakota Fanning oh yeah I got like I
pick up the phone and are like ma'am
and I'm like no I didn't even know there
was a girl's name in Dakota yeah well
yeah man
that's do you like a girl named Sue is
that why you turned out so badass
there you go I kind of feel like when it
came down to Jocko to name his own store
and stuff you it was all cool but when
Amazon names their thing echo it's like
you know yeah a little bit C messed up
no I was on your team no no yeah yeah at
that moment nonetheless hey man I dig it
either way Jocko store.com this is where
you can get shirts discipline equals
freedom good shirt is a good shirt then
when I say the good shirt it's the shirt
was chocolate hit on it says good
backwards so when you look in the mirror
he's telling you good you know I like
that pretty good I get one that's you
went to you too nice
I thought you to Alexa will take care of
you nonetheless junkstock I knew some
rash guards on there some hoodies some
hats patches I gotta restock the patches
are we stuck to everything on there but
the patches yeah hey look I'm trying
over here there's a system in place now
to restock automatically am I correct
well okay I'm not correct it depends on
what you mean by automatically I just
mean things will be in stock from now on
that's our food this immoral bro yeah
he's got two jobs make videos and keep
the store stock yeah how's he do it one
or two
chuckles door commnets room that's
that's the website anyway not saying
goodbye something else look check it out
if you want something get something good
way to support also good way to support
psychological warfare support yourself
ruining your campaign we call it a
campaign against weakness make sense
yeah like it yeah we liked it to some
you suggested to us um you know those
days where you kind of don't feel like
it right and who better to ask for a
little assist on those days than jockle
right in theory right I mean I agree so
boom now we have this album with tracks
chocolate tracks telling you to get how
to get past moments of weakness that may
come up waking up early
skipping work out you know diet stuff on
that um works pretty good that's badass
ten for ten results you'll never skip
work on the program it's okay echo is
like ask me they asked me a question one
time like why do you not stick but how
do you not skip workouts and I was like
wha just buh buh buh yeah well you don't
feel like yeah he's act dude I need to
record that and then he just like asked
me a bunch of random questions and then
we made it into a Rhett recording and we
put it on iTunes for sale it was the
number one spoken word on iTunes for I
think I think until your left 11 months
it finally got knocked out of number one
spoken word by when I released this book
discipline equals freedom Field Manual
on iTunes as a spoken word album so I'm
just saying is I so rarely effective
yeah yeah it's not do this it's no no I
just talk like I'm not a handler you
don't seem like you don't have to you
know yeah you don't have to tell the
guys hey I mean obviously you gotta yell
on the battlefield and you gotta yell
people so they can hear you that's one
thing but yeah I mean I was just talking
as if you have to yell at someone and
you've really screwed something up as a
leader if I gotta yell at you yeah
nonetheless it's yeah very fact like if
you he'll be like there's this one
called sugar-coated lies
right and it's about like you know how
like when you're at work you were
talking about the good video yeah right
yeah so this is the same thing but it's
like a track you can get you can get
actually this the discipline goes
Freedom Field Manual album has good on
there's a track just a track boom there
you go you can put it in your whatever
yeah you can say so and because I had
people come you should make an alarm
clock you should make one crack so when
you did the album with tracks and when
you could use that thing as an alarm
clock so when people ask me for
unlocking like go get the album's
there's three albums now yeah by the way
three albums yeah psychological warfare
and this one is in two different albums
you really only need the first album of
discipline comes freedom Field Manual
fully for the audio yeah you can get
well there's there's well if you want
the knowledge parts yes that's the
second vid the second yeah yeah you
didn't know I was over here so this is
where this is where echo started hammer
hammer me because you know when they
list you they list like psychological
warfare and then they have to list who
made it and it was artist Jaco was like
no no no I'm not artist I just well I'm
just speaking I'm saying works that's
not art no no no no you're an artist I
never looked at you and said well I
don't come across with the artist it's
somewhere in this artsy guy very
effective very effective good way to
support you by the way check also on
Amazon through Alexa if you want you can
order Jaco white tea Amazon a can and
and by the way I don't know if I'll give
you some chocolate white tea and the
reason I'll give it to you isn't I don't
care if you like tea you might not you
might hate tea but what this tea does is
is a guaranteed it's guaranteed to give
you an eight thousand pound deadlift
it's scientifically proven over and over
again the old-line double-blind placebo
tested right there jock whitey eight
thousand pound deadlift yeah so you got
that yeah also hair books for the books
yes get into the fire by Dakota Meyer
and Bing West get it through our website
it's it's an awesome read man a week
week I covered less than ten percent of
the book today you only understand ten
percent of what the
whole situation was by listening to this
podcast get the book support the podcast
at support Dakota learn about what these
brave Americans and Afghans went through
way the warrior kid there's a book I
wrote for kids why cuz who's what kind
of kids what kind of books were kids
reading I know cuz I got four kids my
kids were reading books about lame
people that were being encouraged to be
weak yeah instead of like hey you know
what it's okay to actually get after it
and try and be smarter and try and be
stronger so if you want your kid to be
smarter and stronger and eat healthier
and work harder if that's what you want
you'd get the kid way the warrior kid if
you want to make your child weak and
undisciplined that's cool you can buy
any other book for a kid and that's what
you get and that book did good with
people and I wrote another one it's
called way the war your kid - it's
called Mark's mission and it's got a
whole new genre of issues that mark has
to face with his uncle Jake uncle Jake
comes to help out young mark would you
call him more advanced issues they are
slightly more advanced let me tell you
which one of them one of the one of the
issues that young marks of marks in
sixth grade now in book two he loses his
temper sometimes and he gets in trouble
at school for Hocking a paper mache
pumpkin at another kid's head and it
deflects off his head and hits the
teacher in the face oh man gets he gets
sent home from school last day of school
anyways yeah so learn to control his
temper just like all kids do and I know
this because I got kids and I know this
because I was a kid and you remember
when you were a little kid and you'd
lose your temper and you'd get them
stuff even and when I say little kid I'm
talking like 23 years old get you copy
his uncle in the book is is a seal or
was a seal and he comes to stay with
them for the summer and help some
squared away these little promises I get
yeah
yeah so that's what that one's about he
also learns about working hard he gets a
job starts a business he's 11 years old
has his own business mowing lawns and
pulling weeds that's way the warrior kid
and way the warrior kid to Mark's
mission you can also get speaking of
which warrior kids from Irish Oaks ranch
there's a young warrior kid 12 years old
business owner he makes soap from goat
milk right here in California on his
farm yeah that's cool Wow yeah
well it seems like well how are you -
how did you even why are you talking
about this he got in touch with me and
said I want to make good soap taco soap
and I was like well who are you he's a
comma 12 year-old kid named Aiden I live
on a farm - I'm starting a business I
figure you might want in on the action
Jocko and I was like hey what dude I'm
in Mac Z offer me a piece of the action
I was like oh god yes I'm in man Warren
your kid getting after it and so yeah
you can order that soap at Irish Oaks
ranch
he's bit calm it's you know no big deal
soap Empire right what is like Johnson
and Johnson probably started off making
soap ivory soap do you think Irish soap
doesn't have some good profitability
yeah there's no a difference is the only
difference is this kids starting at 12
guarantee Johnson Johnson didn't start
12
no no started 12 yeah oh yeah yeah get
on there or something you'll have the
kinks worked out before you do the drive
yeah yeah he's all over it I mean I'm
he's manufacturing [ __ ] soap you know
think about when you were two um I mean
let's just let's just get all of our own
no matter our own lose ourselves out of
the table here what were you doing with
your 12 yeah right I was like smearing
boogers on my sisters I was dirt we're
just talking to Lucy I was eating dirt I
didn't know it's so poor like dirt yeah
I I made up the slogan to
simple slogan simple yeah and it's it's
actually great slogan you know what it
is
Jaco Stolp stay clean you got it I gotta
tell you God it would be this good
salami the good song it's like I don't
know I don't know how you came up with
that Jacko's soap stay clean right man
you came out with Junko store yeah Joe's
daughter uh real I'm real creative when
it comes to them them names also hey
another book this clinical freedom Field
Manual if you need to get on the path
stay on the path be on the path move
further down the path if you're having
trouble getting after it in life get the
book this one equals freedom Field
Manual and then don't just get the book
and read it you have to actually do
something that's in it but it's pretty
clear it's a field manual Eko claims to
know all about field manuals my favorite
kind of manual yeah you actually know
about field manuals go ahead to Field
Manual that tells you how to get after
it so you can do that
the audio version of that is not on
audible you can't find it there why
because you couldn't cut it up into
tracts which is what you all asked for
it is on Amazon music Google Play iTunes
as an mp3 also extreme ownership the
book that Lafe babban and I wrote it's
about combat leadership some of the
actually every topic that we talked
about today when it came to leadership
and organizational issues it's all is
all things that are inside extreme
ownership get that and it's not just
about war but it's about life it's about
business and on top of that we have a
leadership and management consulting
company it's called echelon front we
solve problems through leadership every
problem that any organization has can be
solved through one thing in one thing
only
leadership that's it so if you got
problems call us a chillon front me Lafe
babban JP Jenelle Dave Burke Ashlin
front comm of
course also we have the muster it's a
leadership gathering to leadership
gathering seminar conference gathering
and that's what we do we get together we
have all kinds of leaders come we
present we talk about issues we give
pragmatic actual tactics and techniques
on how to lead people if you want to
like come to a conference and get all
happy and clappy and make hugging
promises to the guy that sitting next to
you don't come to this conference that's
not what this conference is we're not
singing and dancing at all no we talked
about we talked about how to lead that's
what it is
so if you want to learn how to lead come
to the to the monster there's only two
of them in 2018 only two of them one of
them Washington DC May 17th and 18th one
of them San Francisco October 17 18th
that's it we're not going to what's name
your hometown Columbia Kentucky we're
not going to Columbia Kentucky for the
muster but we couldn't find we couldn't
we couldn't your barn wasn't big enough
to hold the dish we can we expand it
yeah I'll work on it for next year work
on it we actually did one in Austin if
I'd known you at the time you would have
been there yeah awesome
and let me know if you want to come to
one of these we're not doing it in
Columbia Kentucky we're not doing it in
what's another random place oh my coley
we're not doing it in Hawaii if you want
to come you got to come to one of those
to register by the way they've all sold
out we've done four of them they've all
sold out this one's gonna sell out to
register extreme ownership calm and we
okay we raise the prices once we hit a
certain date why do we do that why do we
raise the prices once we hit a certain
date to make more money no no I'm just
kidding no we actually don't want people
to do that because what the would reason
we do is we want to incentivize people
to register early so that we can block
enough room order enough food plan plan
correctly get the venue set up the right
way so we're trying to make people come
early so we it's actually a penalty
we're penalizing you for being slow and
prefer procrastinating yes
procrastination you're gonna pay that's
right oh it's a procrastination penalty
I like where you're coming from good if
you wait you pay I'll take credit for
that we like people that get up don't
put that as one of Jacko's okay you
running off my lead and I get a little
cut I like it alright so that is that
and until the muster if you have
questions or feedback for us we are we
are ready to receive on the interwebs on
Twitter on Instagram and on - echo is at
Echo Charles and I am at Jocko willing
and Dakota is on the interwebs in a big
way in a big way on Twitter at Dakota
underscore Meijer that's how we linked
up by the way via Twitter I can't
believe you responded to me it's so good
and I'm like I can't believe you said
something to me
couple of little kids on Instagram
Dakota Meyer Oh 317 sniper no just oh
three seventeen Dakota Meyer that's
that's Instagram on Facebook
sergeant Dakota Meyer you can just look
at the co2 Meyer and it pops right up
because you're kind of the man you have
a podcast I do you have your own podcast
it's called owning it owning it with
Dakota Meyer now you you kind of took
that from my book extreme ownership no
big deal
I did take a little slice of that that's
cool you have
Dakota Meyer calm is another place so I
guess that's why I said you're all over
the interwebs because clearly you are
all over the interwebs
you got a YouTube channel yeah I got a
YouTube chance that called it's it's
just Dakota Meyer so I've got the
YouTube channel just Dakota Meyer where
my podcast goes up it's on on the - on
the - what does that mean so you know on
the - comes from a point Linda Ellison
wrote called the - and you know I I felt
like I felt like people in America just
needed something to hold on to and you
know so I always look at what is success
and how do I want to be remembered and
that's kind of like a big thing for me
and I so Linda Ellis wrote an
appointment talked about how
like at a Funeral you know a man stood
to speak and he referred to dates you
know on the tombstone from the beginning
you know with the date the person was
born in the day he died and really those
are the two only two days in your life
that you don't make any decisions or
have any control of and everything else
what matters that - in-between and so
how are you gonna own your - what is
your - gonna look like because you can
control that you can control with that -
looks like how you know how fulfilling
it is how selfish it is how giving it is
I mean you control it by your decisions
every single day and what do you want
your - to look like how do you want to
be remembered because it doesn't matter
how much money you have it doesn't
matter how whatever you did the empire's
you built what matters is how you change
people's lives and that's how you
remembered and where your true
successful in my mind is you'll be
defined will be what people say about
you at your funeral and so that's where
it comes to me is is on the - that's
where the idea of it came from so own
your - you know and you do public
speaking as well I do I do public
speaking get in there and talk to
businesses and teams yeah you know I
come in talk to businesses teams give my
leadership principles of you know what I
believe to make success you know listen
I'm simple though but you know what what
I feel like you know my life I talk
about my story and kind of what happen
to me and then I come around and I what
does that mean to me right what does
that mean like you know every story
without every story or experience that
you go through that doesn't have a
meaning afterwards is a waste experience
and so I talk about that and I just you
know did a lot - a lot of public
speaking trying to I just want to
inspire people I'm like I just you know
I just wanna honestly I just want to
change the world no big deal just want
to change the world that's it no I just
want change the world awesome and it's
it an awesome anything you did I did I
miss anything else no I don't think so I
think that's I think that's everything
yeah anything any other projects
anything else everybody needs to know
about no no listen I can't I can't tell
you how much I appreciate you having me
on
I'm honored to have you on echo you got
anything else no thank you very much for
coming up thank you closing thoughts
Dakota you know listen it's uh I got a
lot of this podcast I got a lot of you
know just hearing your perspective and
you know I just I just want people out
there to know that you know I'm no
different than anybody else the only
difference is opportunities that's been
put in front of me and you know I
appreciate you having me on wellness
it's obviously an honor to have you on
thank you for your thank you for your
service both in the Marine Corps and
what you continue to do now to try and
help people and and just change the
world which is what you're trying to do
now which is awesome and it's been a
true honor to have you on again you know
to be sitting across the table from you
and knowing what you've been through and
to see where you are now is is awesome
and it's it's my honor to be sitting
here and of course to all the servicemen
and women on the battlefields around the
world doing what must be done to protect
us thanks to all of you and finally to
those service members that made the
ultimate sacrifice who gave the last
full measure for us thank you
may you rest in peace
and know without question that we will
never forget and until next time
this is Dakota Meyer and echo and Jocko
out